Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt und äh mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff.
Das hier ist die 99. Ausgabe von UKW und äh ihr habt jetzt einen Monat nix von uns gehört
Heute geht's wieder um die Ukrainer und na ja, nach vier, knapp fünf Wochen ist natürlich mal Zeit für ein Update mit mir und mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wir waren jetzt nicht untätig in der Zeit. Wir haben uns natürlich das Geschehen nach wie vor äh angeschaut. Ist irgendwie auch so ein bisschen äh obskur, wenn man dann so.
Am Strand liegt und dann so macht und Twitter nachliest und äh ja irgendwie versucht dran zu bleiben,
gegen dieses Ermüdungsprinzip.
Kämpfen in gewisser Hinsicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie's dir so geht. Äh es wird ja erst von allen Leuten.
Die Ermüdung vorausgesagt, dass sich der Besten nicht mehr kümmert oder so generell zu viel Krieg kann man nicht die ganze Zeit verfolgen. Das kann ja auch alles ganz gut verstehen.
Sicherlich haben wir jetzt auch nicht mehr so diese tägliche Intensität mit irgendwie jeder Tweet muss gelesen und jeder Linke klickt und nochmal jeder Artikel nachgelesen werden. Trotzdem.
Ja, also ich habe zumindest versucht, äh so ein bisschen am Ball zu bleiben.
Ja ich war ja in der Zeit auch
ja näher am Geschehen äh dran als jemals in meinem Leben zuvor immer noch weit weg, aber in Moldawien in Kiesenau, was ja irgendwie keine hundert Kilometer von Odessa weg ist, also,
zumindest. Insofern äh ja war das auch ein interessanter Einblick äh auch mit den Leuten da äh darüber zu reden äh wie die das denn wahrgenommen haben.
Das aber dazu dann später vielleicht ein bisschen näher im Detail.
Okay, ja in der Tat. Also ich gucke gerade mal, also das wissen vielleicht nicht viele, ist einfach die Hauptstadt von ähm Moldawien.
Und ja, wie du schon sagst, es ist äh in der Tat alles nicht sehr weit weg. Ich ziehe gerade meine Linie. Also in Kilometern bis Odessa, na ja hundert1fünfzig sind's dann schon.
Aber na ja ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich umme E.
Bis zur Ukraine sind äh.
Bis zur Grenze.
Das stimmt wiederum. Gucken wir mal, also Grenze okay, je nachdem wie welche Grenze man nimmt,
Kilometer, äh dann ist es aber auch quasi durch dieses obskure äh Transnistrien durch.
In die andere Richtung auch 50 Kilometer dann hat man tatsächlich ukrainisches Territorium schon vor Augen.
Genau, also da werden wir nachher mal drüber reden, zumal ja die moldarbische Perspektive auch noch mal eine ganz besondere ist.
Nicht wahr? Weil sie da äh potenziell ja in diesem Konflikt auch noch mit reingezogen werden können und natürlich auch eine ganz andere Verquickung haben so mit der ukrainischen Kultur.
Eigentlich wollen wir erstmal anfangen ein bisschen ja zusammenzufassen, wo denn eigentlich der Konflikt grade so steht und das eben jetzt speziell auch.
Mit der militärischen Brille auf, denn leider, leider, leider ist das eigentlich im Wesentlichen das definierende Moment, also der Krieg,
ist einfach als Krieg im Vordergrund und findet nach wie vor in einem sehr breiten Frontverlauf statt.
Ich weiß noch, als wir letzte Sendung hatten, da haben wir im Prinzip einmal alles so geschildert, das war die Erfolge rundum.
Vorstöße. Da hat sich so ein bisschen abgezeichnet oder hat sich zumindest angedeutet, dass es vielleicht möglich wäre für die Ukraine in irgendeiner Form im Norden noch weiter vorzustoßen. Das hat dann nicht so stattgefunden.
Weiß ich nicht entweder der Vorstoß nicht intensiv genug oder der Widerstand zu groß oder beides. Trotzdem.
Ist die Stadt äh KAG ein bisschen ja ich sage mal ein bisschen ähm.
Ruhiger die die Situation, es gibt nach wie vor Raketenangriffe auf die Stadt.
Und auch Artillerieangriffe, also die sind äh wieder die die Russen sind wieder ein bisschen näher rangerückt äh an Khaki.
So in den letzten Tagen, ja, aber also so 5zehn Kilometer äh oder so weg ungefähr. Verläuft die Front jetzt.
Außenbezirken von entfernt.
Hängt immer so ein bisschen davon ab, wo man das so von wo man das so misst, aber es steht da jetzt keine.
Offensiver an, zumindest ist es nicht ersichtlich, dass es eine äh geben wird in nächster Zeit und das hat da eben viel damit zu tun.
Die Russen einfach all ihre Armekraft und vor allem ihrer Artilleriesysteme, was so derzeit ihr größtes Faustpfand sind,
auf diese Ostfront,
konzentriert hat oder konkret halt und das hat mir damit haben wir die letzte Sendung auch so ein bisschen auch äh abgeschlossen an der Stelle. Die Aussage, dass es jetzt um äh,
Geht oder gehen kann und dass dass äh sich dort derzeit alles kulminiert und genau
Ist eigentlich die Geschichte der letzten vier Wochen. Der Kampf um die Stadt, der ist also heiß entbrannt. Die Russen sind sehr stark vorgedrungen und äh die Ukrainer haben's zwischenzeitlich mal geschafft, sie wieder zurückzuschlagen, aber im Wesentlichen
befinden sich die ukrainischen Stellungen, also im Artillerie Dauerfeuer und man kann sich das überhaupt nicht äh vorstellen, glaube ich, wie es da äh abgeht.
Und äh jetzt kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen oder zumindest gehen derzeit alle, die ich so beobachte, davon aus, dass es eigentlich nur eine Frage von Tagen ist
äh die Russen auch
diese Stadt komplett unter Kontrolle haben. So ähnlich wie ein Mariopol ist da halt kein Stein mehr auf dem anderen und es geht auch mal wieder um so einen industriellen Komplex, der jetzt nochmal genommen werden muss.
Ja, wobei die Situation halt ein bisschen schon auch anders äh ist. Auf der einen Seite gibt's halt im äh sozusagen
im Rücken den Fluss oder nur einen Fluss, den sie überqueren müssen oder äh um um auch Nachschub
äh reinzuschaffen. Also es ist jetzt nicht nicht eingekesselt, äh dass das Ganze und irgendwie eigentlich wird seit zwei Wochen fast damit gerechnet, äh dass hm
die äh ja die die Stadt äh,
einnehmen, aber es ist äh wohl immer noch umkämpft, also so richtig geschafft haben sie's bisher nicht. Es spielt
aber äh äh im im Großen und Ganzen Geschehen äh jetzt äh nicht wirklich,
die große Rolle, ob sie das jetzt schaffen oder nicht, äh sondern eher also allein schon, dass sie jetzt da zwei Wochen äh dran kauen und das
wo ja ähm angeblich die russische Seite täglich zwischen 50.000 und 80.000 Granaten.
Feuert, ja? Ja also inklusive jetzt äh Raketen ähm und
äh die Ukraine schafft halt ungefähr nur ein Zehntel davon, also 5tausend bis 6tausend
in die andere Richtung äh zu schicken, was halt auch noch eine ganze Menge ist, aber ganz offensichtlich trotz äh dieser äh eigentlich großen Übermacht
an einigen äh Frontabschnitten, wo die Russen wirklich alles konzentriert und reingeworfen haben, um
eben auch Durchbrüche zu erzwingen. Ähm
es ihnen bisher zumindest weder irgendwie ein größerer Durchbruch noch eine größere Einkesselung gelungen und ähm ja beide Seiten,
haben aber bedauerlich hohe Verluste. Ähm.
So äh Größenordnung 100 Tote am Tag bei den Ukrainern und bis zu 500 Verletzte pro.
Ja und bei den Russen werden die nicht geringer äh sein wahrscheinlich, sondern auch,
mindestens in der selben Größenordnung liegen, wobei sich das Verhältnis ein bisschen zugunsten der Russen verbessert hat. Man sieht es auch an den an den Videos, dass sie versuchen, sich jetzt ein bisschen
besser zu tarnen und ähm nicht mehr auch auch nicht mehr so viele
Truppen und Fahrzeuge irgendwo zu konzentrieren, was natürlich auch ein Problem ist äh und auch nicht zu viel Nachschub irgendwie äh zentral zu halten, aber ähm
alles in in allem ähm so
ist die Ukraine gut dabei äh zurückzuschießen und zu äh treffen und auch halt den Russen äh eine Menge Verluste zu äh bescheren so.
Und ähm insofern also für den Aufwand äh an an an Material äh und die Verluste.
Die Russland hat sind die Fortschritte nach wie vor ja nicht überzeugend.
Nicht ich habe schon gefragt, welches welches Wort du jetzt äh wählst, um das zu bewerten.
Also die ganze ihr werdet ja sicherlich schon mal die eine oder andere Karte gesehen haben, dass es so quasi der östlichste Teil,
der Front, an dem sich das derzeit alles äh konzentriert.
Im äh das ist so eine Nase, die so quasi so äh in diesen Oblast Luans äh noch rein äh ragt.
Und die äh von den Russen, von allen Seiten attackiert wird, also eben konkret in.
In der in der Stadt. Dort sind sie halt äh schon sehr weit gekommen, aber wie schon erwähnt, ähm.
Hohen Aufwand auch äh nur immer wieder mal ein paar Meter pro Tag. Im Norden verläuft ja auch noch dieser Fluss.
Hatten wir glaube ich letzte Mal schon so den Bericht über diese vielen vergeblichen äh katastrophalen Versuche diesen Fluss zu übertreten. Ähm nach wie vor stellt der Fluss weitgehend die die die Frontlinie dar.
Das heißt, da droht nicht ganz so viel, aber im Süden, da ähm stoßen die Russen halt auch in
durch verschiedene Ortschaften äh bedrohlich vor und sind auch relativ nah dran an diesen Versorgungslinien.
Trotzdem scheint's die Ukraine aber noch zu schaffen, dort äh in irgendeiner Form ihre Logistik aufrechtzuerhalten, soweit man das von außen beurteilen kann.
Ich habe neulich mal äh so eine Animation ähm des,
Frontverlaufs des zweiten Weltkriegs gesehen, so jeden Tag dann
der der Frontverlauf gezeigt wurde und wo die Kämpfe waren und das führte natürlich auch einmal komplett durch die Ukraine äh durch und da
kann man dann halt sehen, wie dann ähm sagen auf der einen Seite, wie halt der,
Deutsche beziehungsweise der Vormarsch der Achsenkräfte waren halt auch viele ja auch andere nicht rumänische, bulgarische, andere Truppen beteiligt. Jedenfalls kann man da
ganz gut sehen wie schnell die in der Einrichtung voran äh äh gegangen sind und wie ähm ja,
es dann äh bei der irgendwann bei der Gegenoffensive der Russen äh aussah. Äh wie lange die gebraucht haben, um wiederum äh die Ukraine freizukämpfen, sage ich mal.
Und
da äh hat man schon das Gefühl, obwohl das halt mehrere Jahre ging, also am Anfang eine erstmal eine natürlich eine unglaubliche Dynamik so, aber irgendwann
kam dann wurde's halt eben immer langsamer, immer langsamer bis eigentlich das Ganze erstmal für eine Zeit fast zum Stillstand kam die Fronten, ja. Da bewegte sich dann erstmal nichts, weil beide Seiten einfach dann,
erschöpft waren mehr oder weniger. Und dann gab's hier und da so kleinere Bewegungen und.
Man merkte halt, dass erstmal beide Seiten dann wieder äh ja Kräfte aufbauen, Material reinschaffen mussten, um wieder äh ja die Kampfhandlung intensivieren zu können.
Das ist ja auch etwas, was für die aktuelle Situation gerade vorhergesagt wird, dass das bald so weit kommt.
Ja und äh wir reden aber noch äh außerdem von einem ganz anderen Einsatz an äh Truppen, also.
Operation Barbarossa wurde, glaube ich, mit irgendwie sechs Millionen äh Soldaten äh hat die Achse angegriffen insgesamt.
Ja. So ähm mhm.
Ja
Was lässt sich zu der Situation dort noch äh sagen? Also man könnte jetzt hier viel über den über die Vorstöße äh im Einzelnen sagen, das ist jetzt ein wahrscheinlich für den Podcast im Einzelnen gar nicht jetzt so relevant, nur man kann halt einfach sagen,
In der Summe die Russen machen Fortschritte, aber sie machen keine.
Enormen Fortschritte. Ja, also ich würde mal sagen, in den letzten vier Wochen sind sie äh also die die weiteste Änderung des Frontverlaufs ähm da reden wir so was über,
na ja zehn bis 30 Kilometer Maximum,
an einer Stelle, an den allermeisten Stellen handelt es sich hier äh bestenfalls um um fünf Kilometer.
Es geht also alles sehr schwerfällig voran und es lässt sich einfach auch derzeit überhaupt nicht so richtig sagen.
Äh Kräfte hier zuerst äh enden, definitiv und dann werden wir nachher noch äh drüber reden scheinen die Ukrainer so ein bisschen an das Ende ihrer Vorräte der Munition zu kommen.
Und vielleicht teilweise auch schon ihres Geräts. Das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau. Aber ähnlich sieht's auch bei den Russen aus.
Jetzt gerade in diesem Gebiet also sehr viel Altes Material reinfahren.
Also die scheinen einfach auch Ruheverluste an modernen Waffen gehabt zu haben und jetzt äh wird halt alles aus den Beständen geholt, was noch in irgendeiner Form fahrbar gemacht werden kann.
Ja, also die Ukraine hat zumindest nach eigenen Angaben hm ihre Reserven an Ostmunitionen weitgehend,
aufgebraucht so.
Jetzt kam natürlich auch noch ein bisschen oder kommt wahrscheinlich auch noch ein bisschen, ich sage mal Ostmunition aus dem Westen äh nach. Ich glaube,
äh verschiedene ehemalige Ostblock Länder produzieren da auch Granaten entsprechenden Kalibers kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es da,
in Tschechien zum Beispiel noch Produktionsanlagen gibt. Die bauen ja.
Slowakei auch, in der Slowakei auf jeden Fall.
Slowakei gibt's auch noch, gibt's auch noch ähm auf die Reparatur spezialisierte Unternehmen.
Also insofern ähm.
Wird ähm das jetzt den nicht nicht völlig ausgehen, aber es ist klar, dass ähm,
ja äh einfach erstmal die die Produktion oder die die Anlieferung ähm.
Was jetzt so ich nenne mal Ostmunition äh angeht, also ehemalige sowjetische oder Warschauer Pakt Kaliber
ähm dass das äh nicht ausreichend wird, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass die 5000 bis 6000 Granaten täglich ähm
ja weitgehend eben diese Art von Munition sind und weitgehend aus Reserven stammen, die auch die Ukraine wahrscheinlich noch äh aus Sowjetzeiten übrig behalten hat, weil die die
das Zeugs hat ein ziemlich hohes äh Shelflife, wie man so schön sagt, Haltbarkeitsdatum, also
so die typischen Panzagranaten ähm je nach je nachdem 25 Jahre werden da garantiert
Ähm das heißt aber dann eigentlich nicht schlechter als am Tag der Auslieferung und
fünfunddreißig, 40 Jahre sind jetzt auch nicht unerhört und auch bei den Mehrfachraketenwerfern, die halten wohl, also die in deren Raketen halten wohl sogar noch ein bisschen länger.
Ähm insofern ähm ja.
Äh dürfte der alte Kram, wenn er halbwegs äh ähm brauchbar aufbewahrt wurde, äh aus Sowjetzeiten alles noch funktionieren, aber wie gesagt, der ist jetzt alle
und ähm.
Jetzt ist natürlich das das Problem, dass die Ukraine dann jetzt umstellen muss, wenn sie halt jetzt von den umfangreichen amerikanischen Reserven äh oder von dem, was aus Deutschland
geliefert äh werden soll. Hm wirklich profitieren will.
Ja ähm wollen wir noch kurz vorher die gesamtmilitärische Lage nochmal ähm abschließen und dann vielleicht mal spezifisch auf dieses Waffenthema eingehen.
Ja also.
Wir haben ja noch die die Situation im äh im Süden.
Sagen wir mal im im Südwesten, also im Süden gibt's halt auf der einen Seite die gesamte Frontlinie. Da stehen sich die.
Beiden Kriegsparteien ja schon lange an einer weitgehend unveränderten Linie gegenüber sich mal wieder interessant finde ist, dass der Frontverlauf ja auch unmittelbar an der Großstadt Donetsk.
Vorbeigeht und also vor den Toren sozusagen dieser Stadt an an dieser ähm diesem Frontverlauf sich überhaupt nichts getan hat.
Na ja, es gab wohl jetzt äh hörte ich zumindest so ein paar Angriffe und Vorstöße äh der Ukraine äh in der in der Stadt und auch einen Beschuss äh von äh Donetsk.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass da jetzt äh keine Truppen stationiert werden, aber es es gab halt keine größere Änderungen in dem Frontverlauf, der ist halt eigentlich weitgehend noch so wie zu Beginn dieses Krieges.
Ich habe verschiedene Vorstöße äh oder Versuche der Russen vorzustoßen. Dann äh wurde von der Ukraine auch Dämme, Staudämme äh gesprengt, kleinerer äh Natur und womit so bestimmte Täler,
überflutet wurden,
keine Ahnung, was äh da der Grund ist, ob das einfach nur der Mangel an konzentrierten Kräften ist oder ähm ob's da einfach auch wirklich schwierig ist für die Russen in irgendeiner Form Landgewinn zu machen. Genauso zieht sich das dann eben,
in Richtung Westen.
Zu diesem großen Wasserbecken des äh Dineppa äh südlich von Sapo äh wo.
Irgendwie auch nicht vorangekommen sind, aber viel interessanter ist natürlich die Situation um äh.
Und das ist ja so die Stadt, ähm die die Juristen als die einzige größere Stadt, die die Russen seit diesem Angriff.
Haben einnehmen können. Das ging ja relativ schnell.
Und ja, da ist also Back and Force, nicht wahr? Also nachdem die Russen ursprünglich mal versucht hatten, äh dafür da haben wir ja schon öfter drüber gesprochen, über die Stadt Nikolaiw,
da diesen nächsten Fluss zu überqueren und dann letzten Endes in irgendeiner Form einen Landweg nach Odessa eröffnen zu können, was ja nicht geklappt hat.
Ist also hier der Gegendruck der Ukraine stärker. Jetzt haben die Russen ja auch nicht so viel stationiert und haben sich sozusagen erstmal für den Osten entschlossen, vermutlich auch, um dort erst mal.
Behaupten zu können, man hätte jetzt hier große Erfolge gefeiert, weil man irgendwie Luhansk und äh komplett eingenommen hat, also den ganzen also.
Luhansk zumindest komplett eingenommen hat, den Donbass.
Trotzdem versuchen sie natürlich diese Stadt zu halten, aber die Ukraine macht hier Gegendruck und hat an verschiedenen Stellen Fortschritte erzielt, aber eben auch noch nicht genug, um hier wirklich äh Erfolge zu feiern. Dabei sind die Russen dort eigentlich.
Ziemlich angreifbar, weil's äh ja, da halt einfach.
Nur ein, zwei Brücken gibt, die das so in Richtung Krim äh verbinden und wenn man's in irgendeiner Form gelingen könnte, hier eine strategische Stadt wieder einzunehmen, wovon Ukraine derzeit noch weit entfernt ist, muss man dazu sagen.
Ja dann ähm könnte sich das Blatt hier im Süden wenden.
Ja
was was halt passiert ist, dass natürlich beide Seiten so versuchen Kräfte zu verlagern und zu konzentrieren und auf der einen Seite reagieren, aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch gucken, wo sind,
wiederum Schwächen, gerade des Gegners und weil eben auch Teile sind eben nicht so dicht besetzt, dass jetzt alle zehn Meter jemand im Schützengraben sitzt, ja, sondern ähm da gibt es eben.
Beide Teile, die sind einfach umkämpftes Gebiet und äh von dem aus
wird dann eben auch dann teilweise hinter die äh feindlichen Linien auch immer wieder äh vorgedrungen mit einzelnen Panzern oder äh dann.
Mit Artillerie.
Angriffen natürlich reingewirkt weit ins Gegnerische Gebiet, so dass man ähm ja ähm das jetzt nicht überall äh ich sage mal oder oder an den wenigsten Stellen jetzt, sondern.
Sage mal Stacheldraht-Verhau äh ist wie im ersten Weltkrieg, ja wo keiner durchkommt und ähm sondern das ist halt alles.
Deutlich ähm lockerer, sage ich mal, äh.
Ja, ich meine, der Frontverlauf ist ja auch äh mega lang, ne? Also ich habe mal ein paar schöne Vergleiche äh gesehen, da wurde mal das besetzte Gebiet.
Von den Russen äh besetzte Gebiet wurde mal so auf westeuropäische Länder gemappt sich einfach mal so einen konkreten.
So ein konkretes Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, wie groß ist diese Fläche eigentlich? Hast du da irgendwie aus dem Bauch heraus eine Vermutung?
Ähm im Vergleich zu was soll jetzt Ukraine oder das das besetzte Gebiet?
Es geht um um das derzeit von den Russen insgesamt besetzte Gebiet der Ukraine. Wenn du das jetzt irgendwie so nimmst die Fläche und irgendwie anders anordnest ähm was würdest du meinen,
Welche westeuropäischen Länder würde das so abdecken?
Ja, eher sagen, also es ist in der Größenordnung von einigen größeren Bundesländern auf jeden Fall vielleicht ein Drittel von Deutschland oder so, würde ich schätzen.
Nicht schlecht geschätzt. Also es ist zum Beispiel Österreich und Schweiz zusammen. Ja also man würde sich jetzt mal vorstellen ähm die Russen hätten halt Österreich und die Schweiz komplett besetzt.
Das ist halt äh der Umfang der Operation, von der wir äh sprechen und entsprechend bereit ist, dann halt eben auch der Frontverlauf.
Na ja, also äh derzeit äh sind auf jeden Fall die Ukrainer noch in der Lage, die Russen
in irgendeiner Form am Vordringen zu hindern, nicht so, dass sie gar nicht äh irgendwo vorkommen, aber sodass sie es halt äh Content machen, eben unter,
großen Verlusten und äh hinzunehmendem Maße halt auch unter großen personellen Verlusten,
Das spielt natürlich eine Rolle. Das ist ja auch keine reine Zahlendreherei, sondern das hat natürlich auch was damit zu tun, dass ähm auch die Ukraine sehr erfahrene Soldaten natürlich verliert mit der Zeit.
Hier äh,
gehen ihnen halt auch dann Leute verloren, die einfach wichtig sind für die Strategie, die diese ganze Erfahrung der letzten Jahre im Konflikt mit Russland haben, was ja bisher der Ukraine sehr geholfen hat.
Auf der anderen Seite, äh so hat die Ukraine jetzt keinen Mangel, äh ich sage mal Leuten, die auch motiviert sind und,
kämpfen und sich ausbilden lassen wollen, also äh es werden wohl grade in der Größenordnung von äh Jahrhunderttausend äh weiteren Soldaten ausgebildet
in der Ukraine. Problem ist vor allem, die eben zu bewaffnen und auszurüsten, so. Äh daran mangelt es halt in,
in erster Linie
und äh ja bei den Russen ist die Begeisterung äh nicht so groß äh
in diesen Kampf zu ziehen und versuchen halt jetzt dann ja vor allem mit Geld äh Leute anzuwerben und indem sie jetzt auch das Anwerbealter glaube ich auf sechzig hochgesetzt haben.
Also im Prinzip äh ja versuchen.
Nehmen.
Im Prinzip nehmen Sie jeden theoretisch gerade.
Aber nicht hin.
Also sie haben schon äh durchaus ihre Probleme äh Leute nach zu ähm nachzuschieben. Allerdings ist halt auch ein großes Land so, also äh
paar fallen dann halt trotzdem drauf rein oder sind irgendwie in ihrem,
ja nationalistischen Waren äh äh ausreichend verrückt sich hier äh als Kanonenfutter einstellen zu lassen.
Zunehmenden Maße greift sie halt auch auf äh
Konstkript zurück, also Leute die gerade erst eingezogen wurden, obwohl das halt alles überhaupt nicht äh erlaubt ist, aber das äh scheint die Russen an der Stelle auch nicht weiter zu kümmern.
Ja.
Ja ähm wir haben's ja schon angedeutet Waffen, das Waffenthema dominiert.
Auch die internationale Diskussion und vor allem ist es auch immer wieder das, was die Ukraine selber,
betont, die Waffenversorgung ist Ki, denn,
werden, können sie sich selber, sagen sie, aber wir brauchen halt entsprechendes Gerät und seit Monaten gibt's halt den Schrei nach schweren Waffen, nach vielen Munitionen et cetera PP, aber wie wir jetzt eben gerade schon auch
klargemacht haben. Ist ja noch eine andere Transition, die hier stattfindet, weil in dem Moment, wo einfach das ganze Ostmaterial ausgeht.
Das ist halt perspektivisch irgendwann der der Fall, also Munition, Panzer alles wird halt irgendwann im Eimer sein. Ähm.
Ist halt die Frage, äh wo kriegt man's her und man kriegt's halt nur teilweise aus den Altbeständen Tschechiens, der Slowakei, Polen, äh Poles et cetera, vielleicht äh weiß ich nicht, Rumänien, Bulgarien,
inwiefern die hier noch engagiert sind, aber die Bestände sind natürlich da auch nicht so riesig.
Nie und das waren natürlich alles Dinge.
Und die bisher äh ja als erstes natürlich geliefert äh wurden, weil ähm die halbwegs kompatibel sind äh die Leute wissen, wie die zu warten und zu bedienen sind und
äh das galt dann halt auch politisch als irgendwie nicht so heikel. Ähm aber
ist, äh dass jetzt eben die Ukraine äh halt mit jedem Tag mehr abhängig wird von westlichen Waffenlieferungen, das heißt der Westen hat es eben jetzt auch zunehmend letztlich in der Hand äh wie gut
oder wie schlecht äh ja äh es den Ukrainern äh gelingt äh sich zur Wehr zu setzen.
Und ähm ja könnte sagen, das entwickelt sich damit halt schon einfach hin auch zu einem klassischen Stellvertreterkrieg.
Weil ähm ich meine, wir liefern Waffen, wir liefern Aufklärung äh Expertenausbildung äh so ähm,
was ähm ja was fehlt denn noch, um das halt stellvertretender Krieg zu bezeichnen, nicht mehr wirklich viel, ne.
Nee, das ist der totale. Also das
macht man sich wird's vielleicht jetzt nicht sonderlich betont, aber ich denke, dass es jedem klar dass wir jetzt hier einfach äh in einen Konflikt,
ähm reininvestieren einfach, um die Kosten in der Zukunft noch niedriger zu halten, ne. Ich glaube, das ist auch das, was vielen Leuten nicht.
Klar ist, gerade in dieser ganzen Debatte mit, ja, nee, ach und überhaupt, das Leid wird ja nur verlängert, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie hier noch Waffen reinliefern
nach dem Motto der Ukraine hat doch sowieso keine Chance, lässt auch einfach die Russen machen, nur
Das ist genau die Politik, mit der wir jetzt diese Situation bekommen haben und vielleicht hätten verhindern können, wenn man diesen Kurs früher aufgegeben hätte.
Ja die Rechnung ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach so. Also alles das, was man jetzt in diesen Krieg investiert und das ist natürlich nicht nur Waffenlieferung und die Kosten, die unmittelbar damit zu tun haben, sondern wir investieren ja sozusagen auch.
Preise, höhere Energiepreise, äh geschwächte Lieferketten, et cetera, also der ganze Rattenschwanz, der da dranhängt, Inflation et cetera.
Uns mal bei den Waffenlieferungen bleiben.
Noch weil da gibt's glaube ich noch einiges zu zu sagen und ähm ja mein hier Gabi Kaspa, auf der er da auch sehr äh ähm.
Aktiv ist auf Twitter, in der Sache ehemaliger russischer Schachweltmeister unter anderem. Ähm.
Ja, der meinte so, ja, The West ist äh Handing-out, weapons by the spoon, ja also das ist halt der Westen bisher nur löffelweise äh Waffen liefert, ähm und,
Die Frage ist ja, ist die Kritik jetzt eigentlich berechtigt und ähm wie viel äh es denn jetzt tatsächlich geliefert worden oder wird geliefert und,
da ist es so, dass bei Artillerie und Granaten der Westen wohl bisher rund 10 Prozent seiner Bestände geliefert hat. Ja, was durchaus substanziell ähm ist, so, das,
kann man nicht äh ja.
Welcher Westen Europa oder einschließlich der USA?
Äh ja also US USA und also jetzt sozusagen das war jetzt so eine äh Angabe aus der aus der Ukraine äh das jetzt was so eben bei Artillerie und Granaten jetzt äh bisher geliefert wurde.
Aber nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt äh was die USA geliefert haben 10 Prozent ihrer Bestände sind.
Ne?
Sie haben ja allein von diesen Haubitzen haben sie ja noch irgendwie Unmengen.
Na ja, wie gesagt, das ist das, was äh das ist die Zahl, die ich von ukrainischer Seite äh äh gehört habe.
Und ähm interessant ist aber, dass es halt auch im Zweiten Weltkrieg, also am Anfang
in den USA dieselbe Kritik gab äh wie man sie heute halt lesen kann an den langsam
anlaufenden viel zu geringen Waffenlieferungen an England und Deutschland hat ja aber wirklich auch ganz Europa überrannt damals oder die,
Achse und nur England äh war da jetzt äh noch äh ja das das Bollwerk äh das irgendwie Amerika
Äh da verteidigte und ähm ja auch gesagt, ja und äh Engländer und viel zu wenig und viel zu langsam, aber was man eben auch so ein bisschen unterschätzt, dass natürlich.
Normalerweise in Friedenszeiten ja die Produktion auch eher gering,
so von von Waffen, da wird halt auch nicht so viel verbraucht, aber wenn halt so ein so ein Krieg kommt, dann äh dauert das natürlich überhaupt erstmal und allein
nur die die Logistik. Ähm
Also ähm aber was ich gehört habe haben mittlerweile vor allem die Amerikaner halt äh ja fast sowas wie eine Luftbrücke aufgebaut,
Polen und äh in Polen halt
und teilweise auch in anderen Ländern, aber ich glaube hauptsächlich in Polen eben riesige ähm ja Verladezentren äh im Grunde genommen aufgebaut, wo
wo halt äh jetzt richtig Material äh reingeschafft äh wird. Aber ähm.
Das läuft halt jetzt gerade erst an. Ein weiteres Problem ist,
Das halt viel von dem Material, was bisher geliefert wurde und jetzt auch immer noch direkt an die Front geht,
So, das heißt, äh wenn du aber jetzt
wirklich eine Gegenoffensive äh Unternehmen äh willst, so dann musst du erstmal Kräfte sammeln, dann musst du irgendwie deine Reserven aufbauen, dann kannst du nicht halt alles gleich an die Front schicken, aber natürlich kann denen das niemand verdenken.
Wenn die grade so eine Übermacht gegenüberstehen, dass sie eigentlich alles verschießen wollen äh im Moment, was was da ist und jetzt ist natürlich sehr schwer fällt,
in dieser Situation äh jetzt wirklich erstmal größere Reserven äh aufzubauen und,
Da rechnen eben alle damit, dass das irgendwie noch Monate äh dauern wird, bis wenn alles gut läuft
bis die Ukraine vielleicht genügend Reserven aufgebaut hat um äh in die Offensive zu gehen, aber die Russen werden natürlich in der Zeit jetzt auch nicht äh untätig äh bleiben. Ähm,
nur hm wird es dann,
irgendeinem Punkt äh eben auch darauf ankommen oder kommt halt bisher auch schon drauf an, dass ähm.
Man halt einfach auch trifft und einfach die vorhandenen Waffen, wenn es denn dann modernere oder bessere Waffen sind, eben auch einfach effizienter einsetzt.
So, was ja bisher halbwegs zu gelingen scheint, auch auch der der Ukraine. Und.
Diese Debatte kam jetzt natürlich auch auf im Zusammenhang jetzt mit dem großen Jubel, dass die deutsch-holländischen Panzerhaubitzen 2000 endlich angekommen sind. Ganze sieben Stück
so ja.
Meine das, wo die Ukraine, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, äh ja mehrere hundert äh
Systeme bisher im im Einsatz hat, also jetzt von, sagen wir mal, Panzerhaubitzen äh so, also Hunderte zwischen, ich glaube, fünfhundert
tausend Stück oder so da äh klingen natürlich sieben Stück erstmal doch ein bisschen bescheiden. Ähm wobei
ja die Dinger immerhin ausreichen so um äh
schon äh dann so einen Bataillon äh damit auszurüsten, keine Ahnung.
Die die jetzt zusammenhalten oder irgendwie aufteilen und für spezielle Zwecke dann dann einsetzen, aber ja
Ähm wäre gut, wenn sie eher 70 Stück äh davon hätten statt äh sieben, aber Bundeswehr hat glaube ich nur hundert10 oder so.
Und ähm ansonsten ja dann gab's gab's halt so ein bisschen die Mythos ja aber dann,
meines stimmt auch äh diese äh so eine Panzerhaubitze 2tausend, wenn die richtig eingesetzt äh wird. Äh die.
Ist extrem präzise so, da,
ist dann halt schon eigentlich so ein bisschen äh ja jeder Schuss ein Treffer äh so ein ist dann angeblich weil äh die Deutschen halt
äh nicht so viel Geld für Munition ausgeben wollten, beziehungsweise dass man.
Dann halt äh eben nicht daneben schießen durfte, dass das halt verboten äh waren so.
Daneben schießen.
Schießen verboten äh so.
Während äh so ein bisschen also sozusagen da habe ich
ist so eine jeder Schuss ein Trefferdoktrin äh angeblich gab während äh in der USA
um die Doktrin galt, dass äh wir jedes militärische Problem äh mit dem Einsatz von mehr Sprengstoff gelöst werden kann. Ähm.
Was jetzt irgendwie auch der russische Ansatz zu sein scheint aber beides ist tatsächlich.
Eher einen einen Mythos, also gerade Deutschland hatte faktisch mit sage mal Präzisions äh Waffen also mit den Fähigkeiten, die halt
hauptsächlich jetzt Luftwaffe, aber eben auch andere einfach Präzisionswaffen war da weit äh hinterher den anderen NATO äh
und ähm
Ja in in Vietnam hat die USA tatsächlich äh noch versucht mit wirklich viel Sprengstoff und mit ich glaube
im Schnitt 1,1 Millionen Schuss pro getöteten Gegner, die abgefeuert wurden, ja.
Gut.
Äh also mit solchen äh und eigentlich weiß man auch spätestens schon seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg, dass man mit Bomben alleine, also war jetzt so, ich ja als Fallschirmjäger kriegte man dann natürlich,
schon die Legende äh dann von äh dem heroischen äh Kampf der Fallschirmjäger äh in Monte Casino, so ein Kloster, wo wirklich die Amerikaner dann mit
etlichen Luftangriffen wirklich versucht haben, dort Apfelwagenkloster aufm Berg.
Und die haben irgendwie weiß nicht, 30 Meter vom Berg abgetragen mit ihren Bomben und kamen dann aber trotzdem nicht durch so. Also ich würde sagen
ganz so einfach ist es dann eben doch nicht. Also mit äh Einsatz von mehr Sprengstoff
kann man eben dann doch nicht alle Probleme lösen, sondern treffen es äh da einfach einfach besser,
Und äh man sehen aber sieben Panzerhaubitzen 2000 sind sicherlich
sehr nett und auch eine eine Hilfe, aber äh so im im Gesamtausmaß äh ja äh spielen die jetzt erstmal nicht die die große Rolle, aber vielleicht kommen ja mehr nach. Eröffnet ja vielleicht eine.
Kommen mehr nach. Was man dazu auch noch sagen muss, es ist ja auch nicht so ausreichend, so einfach so ja okay, hier ist die neue Waffe, äh die stellen wir jetzt da mal hin, jetzt schießt mal los, alles super. Sondern das muss ja sozusagen auch integriert.
Ja, ja, aber da gab's ja Nachrichten, wie die hier Trainingslehrgänge gemacht haben an der Panzerhaubitz.
Trainingslager, um es um es zu benutzen, aber es hat natürlich auch was mit
Integration in das ganze zu tun. Ich meine so eine Panzerhaubitze, die schießt auch nur dann präzise, wenn sie genau weiß, wo sie hinschießen muss und dazu muss diese Information natürlich in dieses System rein.
Äh reden wir eben von Software, da reden wir von Protokollen, reden wir von von Datenübertragung, Standards et cetera. Sicherlich alles Sachen, die in den letzten Monaten
intern ausgiebig diskutiert wurden, aber die dann halt umgesetzt werden mussten. Und was wir jetzt ohnehin gerade sehen, ist halt nicht nur so eine.
Nicht nur eine Belieferung mit neuen Waffen, sondern gerade da ja nun perspektivisch eigentlich auch der ganze Ost.
Oder Warschauer Pakt Standard, Waffensatz einerseits.
Verbraucht sein wird ja also Munition ist verschossen, Geräte sind äh kaputt so. Es kommt jetzt immer mehr aus dem Westen. Es ist ja perspektivisch.
Auch klar, dass auch die nächsten zehn, 20 Jahre Ukraine im Wesentlichen seine Waffen entweder selber produziert.
Ne, also
ist ja ein Waffenproduzierendes Land, auch wenn jetzt viele der Fabriken natürlich auch von den Russen angegriffen wurden, keine Ahnung, wie gut ihre Produktion derzeit so aussieht.
Aber so rein technisch, wenn sie natürlich jetzt in zunehmenden Maße sich auf den NATO-Standard.
Reinigen. Also es ist so eine schleichende Nato-Ifizierung auf technischer Ebene, die jetzt eben durch diese äh Lieferung ausgelöst wird und sicherlich dann auch in Zukunft so weitergehen wird.
Wobei die Waffenindustrie der Ukraine
eben auch gegenüber Sowjetzeiten äh noch massiver reduziert wurde als die Waffenindustrie in Russland ähm so, weil einfach
ähm die Ukraine es jetzt nicht geschafft hat große,
Erfolge zu erzielen, hier und da. Vereinzelt aber äh sagen, Export war nicht so das große Ding und nach dem Bruch dann vor allem mit Russland, waren eben auch das eigene Militärbudget, was sie halt
aufbringen konnten, äh war halt einfach zu gering um
Eben eine große eigene Rüstungsindustrie äh wirklich das Talent und die Produktionsanlagen.
Überall zu erhalten und haben natürlich dementsprechend eben eine ganze Menge Fähigkeiten auch verloren.
So dadurch aber ja.
Trotzdem kommt jetzt interessantes Material perspektivisch an.
Also wir haben jetzt gesagt, Panzerhaubitzen, die äh Amerikaner haben ihre M sieben sieben schon äh in großer Zahl geliefert, die Franzosen haben ihr äh Cäsar-System diese äh Hobbysen auf Rädern.
Geliefert die Panzerhaubitze ist ja wie der Name schon nahe liegt auf äh Ketten. Ja also alles.
Hochmobile Systeme, alle sehr anders, ne? Die amerikanische Haubitze wird einfach hinten angehängt, die ähm französische Hauptpitze fährt selber durch die Gegend auf Reifen und die Deutsche fährt auf Ketten. Ähm.
Dazu werden jetzt noch Raketensysteme äh kommen. Da gab's ja auch viel Hickhack drumherum. Das äh diese Raketenwerfer
zwar geliefert werden, aber mal so ein bisschen Bedenken hatte, dass die Ukraine die dann benutzt, um äh Stellung auch in Russland anzugreifen, dass dann wiederum etwas, was der Westen gerne verhindern möchte. Dementsprechend wurden die dann ähm was die auch mit anderen Raketen ausgeliefert oder in irgendeiner Form mit einer Beschränkung, dass sie halt nicht ganz so weit können.
Wie äh sie sonst könnten.
Ja ja, also es gibt Munition. Ich glaube die Munition, die sie jetzt kriegen, geht bis 70 Kilometer. Es gibt eben aber auch Munition, die bis über 300 Kilometer schafft für dieselben.
Aber ich freue mich, warum.
Die haben sich ja von der Ukraine jetzt zusichern lassen, so ja, könnt ihr haben, aber bitte nix in Russland angreifen. So und das.
Die Ukraine dann auch zugesagt? Nur äh frage ich mich warum eigentlich.
Und ähm das schließt ja dann auch aus, dass so Ziele wie die Krimbrücke angegriffen werden.
Wobei.
Wo man ja sagen könnte, das ist ja sozusagen ukrainisches Gebiet.
Ähm wobei ich nicht glaube, äh.
Dass dass irgendeine, also ich ich glaube selbst die Amerikaner werden nicht in der Lage äh diese Krimbrücke wirklich zu zerstören. Ich glaube nicht, dass,
Militär äh dazu derzeit äh wirklich in der Lage ist. Also nicht nicht so, dass sie äh nicht innerhalb von ein paar Tagen wieder repariert werden kann. Also ähm.
Das ist ich meine bei Brücken
im Moment bemühen sich auch äh die die Russen äh gerade ab, so eine ukrainische Brücke äh da zu zerstören und haben ich weiß nicht wie viel Luftangriffe drauf geflogen und das Ding weigert,
sich einfach zusammenzufallen und gibt so viele Beispiele einfach vor.
Welche? In welcher Region, welche.
Ich weiß es nicht, nicht nicht genau, aber ich höre ab halt äh da nur einen Bericht gesehen von ein von ein paar Wochen, wo äh ja äh
auch äh in den Zusammenhang und wie gesagt auch im zweiten Weltkrieg gab's das Beispiel oder auch in Vietnam äh die Amerikaner, wo es äh nicht nicht gelungen ist und,
Also Brücken äh zu zerstören, äh selbst so einfache aus aus Stahl ist schon schwierig genug und
äh das Ding, ich weiß nicht, äh ob du so Bilder präsent hast, das ist ein ziemlich massives Bauwerk, von dem wir da reden, ja.
Also und meistens äh äh
machst du da halt irgendwo Löcher rein, aber so richtig, dass das irgendwie zusammenfällt, da müsstest du schon zwei der größeren Stützpfeiler oder so wegkriegen und das ist irgendwie ja massiver Beton und äh
das halte ich für äh unwahrscheinlich, dass das gelingen würde, die wirklich.
Zu zerstören, also mit ja konventionellen Waffen. Ganz ganz schwierig.
Okay. Was nicht kommt bisher sind richtige Panzer.
Ja also.
Darüber ist irgendwie auch noch überhaupt nicht.
So schön heißt äh Kampfpanzer westlicher Bauart, weil Panzer östlicher Bauart wurde ja.
Und,
Ich meine ja da gab's halt dann heute auch die Debatte, wo dann die äh CDU die Regierung kritisiert hat. Sie würde aber irgendwie ganz schön verbal Akrobatik betreiben, weil nämlich
in dem Zusammenhang halt der Marder
der eigentlich ja eher einen Panzerkampfwagen ist, trotzdem als Kampfpanzer gilt, ja, während aber,
Gepard und die Panzerhaubitze 2tausend, die einfach mal auf einem Panzerfahrgestell basieren, ja ähm so äh beide.
Ähm gelten nicht als Kampfpanzer.
Beide können aber, glaube ich, sogar auch, also auf jeden Fall der Gepard kann halt auch im direkt Mode zur Bekämpfung von Bodenzielen eingesetzt werden, ja?
Und
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie's bei der Panzerhaubitze 200 ist. Ich glaube, die hat sogar auch einen Boot, wo man irgendwie quasi direkt äh äh schießen kann. Also die wie eine wie ein wie wie eine Panzerkanone benutzen kann. Ja,
wie viel Sinn das macht.
Aber die sind natürlich nicht so beweglich. Die haben ja äh riesiges Rohr und haben nicht diese äh diese Flexibilität, die jetzt im Kampf.
Nee, man würde das nicht, aber.
Schon ja.
Ja, aber sozusagen
die die Unterscheidung jetzt sozusagen keine äh äh Panzer westlicher Bauart ist so ein bisschen na ja ähm also
ja so richtig.
Ich wollte nur festhalten, also so Leopard Panzer oder Ebrams aus den USA. Ich meine die äh.
USA, die haben da komplette Wüsten voll stehen mit diesen Panzern. Davon haben die so richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig viele und selbstverständlich äh könnten sie anfangen so eine Seebrücke zu machen und sagen, so jetzt geht's aber los.
Nur die Frage ist ähm wird das noch passieren.
Äh warum ist es bisher noch nicht passiert äh in welchem Maße meint man denn jetzt hier ähm so eine,
Initiative, die irgendwann ja ansteht, haben wir ja schon erwähnt, also wenn man die Russen jetzt wirklich verjagen will, dann muss man sehen.
So richtig um die Ohren hauen, so. Das wird halt einfach ohne eine massive Landforce überhaupt nicht möglich sein und das geht jetzt mit den Alten, also mit den Kampfpanzern östlicher Bauer, dafür sind aber nicht genug da.
Also ähm ich
würde vermuten äh ja, dass irgendwann natürlich auch Panzer äh kommen, weil das macht halt keinen Sinn und die,
Verteidigungsministerin klang auch so hm als wenn man grundsätzlich bereit wäre, aber eben keinen Alleingang machen möchte, sondern dass das halt wenn dann im Bündnis
abgestimmt äh äh werden müsste.
Und sagen, man schiebt so ein bisschen jetzt von deutscher Seite aus äh die äh Verantwortung dafür auf die NATO oder die Amerikaner letztlich die ähm.
Da äh bestimmen und oder den Vorreiter machen sollen, ja. So, das heißt,
sobald irgendjemand anfängt dann oder die Amerikaner sich dann entscheiden äh auch Panzer äh zu liefern, so wird wahrscheinlich dann auch Deutschland
zum Beispiel zustimmen, dass die Spanier, die ja Panzer, die zwei angeboten haben, äh,
habe ich hundert Stück oder so äh dann wird auch Deutschland sein okay geben, aber vorher nicht. Ja.
Ist klar, aber es ist ja, geht ja auch nicht nur in Deutschland die Frage, sondern im Prinzip an die ganze NATO.
Also würde sagen.
Eine ganze Menge Länder sind dazu bereit, aber man hat halt äh da ähm ja kein kein Konsens äh bisher an der Stelle. Also es gibt offensichtlich auch Länder, die die dort bremsen. Ähm und.
Du hast dir aber auf jeden Fall ein System genauer angeschaut, was äh auch noch geliefert werden soll, was in ähm Luftkampf zum Einsatz kommen könnte.
Also äh das ist es äh Iris T System und da,
soll jetzt leider nur oder was heißt leider nur, immerhin, dass äh sogenannte Iris T SLM System geliefert werden,
und äh um zu erklären.
Muss man äh ja vielleicht äh zunächst mit äh sagen der oder Iris TSLM zu erklären, muss man halt mit beginnen und äh,
Iris T kannte ich bisher nicht nicht wirklich, war mir war mir so kein Begriff.
Und ähm als ich mich dann ein bisschen schlau gemacht habe, äh war ich dann doch
sehr erstaunt äh darüber, dass äh wir sowas auch im im Arsenal haben und hm im Prinzip Irestie
wurde halt als Nachfolger für die Sideweinder Luft Rakete entwickelt und
Zwar stellt man fest, als dann.
Das alte NVA-Material äh bei der bei der Bundeswehr dann war, äh dass darunter eben auch sowjetische Wimpel R 73 Raketen waren, äh wo man fest,
gestellt hat, dass die wesentlich leistungsfähiger als die Sidefinder äh waren. Die amerikanischen und so hat man sich dann entschlossen
sogar eine Luft-Luft-Rakete zu entwickeln, also für den Luftkampf, die.
Ja besser ist als die sowjetische Wimpel R 73 und
da haben sich dann offensichtlich wirklich ein paar Nerds ausgetobt, also da wollte man's tatsächlich offenbar wissen.
Und ähm ich habe dann mal geguckt, was denn so die Militärcommunity
von Iris T hält und dann findet man natürlich an so Seiten wie äh die zehn besten Luft-Luft-Raketen äh für Kurzstrecke.
Siehe da so fand sich da zumindest 216 in einer Liste auf Platz eins, also wegen der feuchte Traum äh eines jeden
Piloten äh so an an Luft-Luft-Rakete und
die Dinger sie haben's auch noch geschafft, die Dinger vergleichsweise günstig zu machen, also vierhundert äh vierhunderttausend äh Euro äh neunhundert Dollar ähm.
Pro Stück äh so, was halt äh aber für das, was äh die Dinger die Dinger leisten äh einfach unglaublich ist und ähm,
so gut man muss natürlich sagen, bisher ist Irest T noch nie in einem echten Krieg äh eingesetzt worden, ja, das heißt
äh man äh hat diese Daten alle nur aus Tests, die man durchgeführt hat äh jetzt, aber
Erstmal ist das Ding extrem manövrierfähig, kann irgendwie mit 60 Gerbeschleunigung äh in die Kurve gehen, das ist mehr als jeder andere.
Luft
Luftrakete dieser Bauart. Sie kann nach dem Abschuss um 180 Grad wenden. Also du kannst sie halt dann nach vorne abschießen und dann fliegt die halt einfach,
um und äh äh greift halt das Flugzeug hinter dir oder wo auch immer es ist äh an. Dann,
Äh das Besondere gegenüber allen anderen äh
oder Suchköpfen ist, äh dass die so einen Suchkopf hat, der ähm einen zweiteiliges CCD benutzt, was halt rotiert wird.
Und ähm dadurch,
kann man halt sehr präzise Blenden machen, die dafür sorgen, äh dass das Ding mit flairs praktisch,
nicht abzulenken ist, ja?
Also Fler ist das sind so diese hellen ja Brennelemente, die so abgeworfen werden, um äh entsprechende Raketen abzulenken, zu sagen, ja hier ist es heiß, fliegt hierhin.
So, also wie gesagt, das ist die ist wohl äh einfach ja Flers helfen da einfach nicht.
Dann
hat sie natürlich auch, aber das haben haben auch viele sagen das sogenannte das heißt, wenn man versucht sie mit einem Laser zu blenden, dann benutzt sie den Laser zur,
ja, dann fliegt sie halt den Laser an, aber
Ähm sie benutzt außerdem im Endanflug Radar, so das knipst sie dann an, was eben auch für so eine eigentliche Infrarot-Rakete äh schon
ja ungewöhnlich ist und,
außerdem kennt sie die acht verwundbarsten Stellen bekannter Flugzeugtypen und steuert eben eine äh davon an,
ja?
Erkennt sie auch das Flugzeug oder ist das etwas, was man.
Ja ja, sie erkennt das Flugzeug, genau, sie erkennt das Flugzeug und sagt dann, okay, das ist das Flugzeug und da äh treffe ich am besten irgendwie hier dort oder da. Ja.
So. Ja und äh.
Das alles macht äh Sie auch so genau, also äh wo's halt nicht nur in der Lage sein, jetzt das Flugzeug irgendwo zu treffen.
So und äh normalerweise die klassischen Raketen treffen dann irgendwo am Triebwerk, wo es dann am heißesten ist, ja. Aber das macht die halt nicht, sondern die guckt sich irgendeine andere Stelle aus und muss eben dann auch in der Lage sein, weil sie einen
Flugzeug, was sich mit Überschallgeschwindigkeit bewegt, nicht nur irgendwo zu treffen, sondern an einer bestimmten Stelle zu treffen. Und das macht's.
So für Stellen.
Ähm
Na ja äh ich vermute mal äh so äh einmal dort, wo der wo der Pilot sitzt, weil wenn du den Piloten ausschaltest äh so, dann äh ja
fliegt das Flugzeug auch nicht mehr weiter, ja? Das ist so die verwundbarste Stelle, zumal du dann halt zumal der Pilot oft wertvoller ist, äh als das Flugzeug
Ja? Insofern würde ich mal sagen da die Waffenhersteller äh ja.
Davon aus, dass sie ja maximalen Schaden natürlich verursachen äh äh werden, das heißt äh ja können wir vorstellen, dass die dann halt einfach auch das Cockpit anfliegen zum Beispiel.
So und die Genauigkeit dafür dafür haben sie äh halt ja.
Und äh sie sind so genau das man wahrscheinlich damit auch gegnerische Raketen abschießen kann.
Ja, das heißt, so in einem Feuergefecht kannst du halt dann die Sidewinder von dem anderen halt abschießen.
Und äh ja äh wie gesagt also wirklich
äh als Luftluft Raketen sind die Dinger erstmal echte so und gelten, gut es gibt jetzt einen neueren Nachfolger, der wohl noch besser äh sein soll.
Aber ähm was man eben auch gemacht hat äh aus Irest T ähm.
Ist, äh dass der Hersteller das Ganze erweitert hat, äh zu einer Luftabwehrrakete, die vom Boden aus abgeschossen wird und das ist die Aristee SLM.
Die.
Launch Media meistens dann, ne? Also surface launcht medium rangerom ist komplett.
Genau, es gibt dann wohl auch noch die SLS, die verschießt im Prinzip äh ganz normale Iristees, äh die halt auch vom Flugzeug äh abgeworfen werden, aber die SLM hat halt
zwar den denselben äh Suchkopf äh so und
ähm ähnliche Steuerung, hat aber eben es ist größer und äh länger und hat eine größere Reichweite halt bis zu 40 Kilometer vom Boden aus, äh während
Iris T halt fünfundzwanzig Kilometer aus der Luft schafft und so zehn, 15 Kilometer äh vom Boden aus wahrscheinlich.
So und ähm ja, ich fand's schade, dass äh dass die Ukrainer nicht auch Aristee, Luft
Raketen für ihre Mix äh geliefert bekommen, weil ähm theoretisch zumindest,
äh müssten die in der Lage sein, die Dinger auch abzuschießen, weil nämlich die Russen halt äh damals die Sidewiner nachgebaut haben.
Und äh dementsprechend halt
die russische Rakete Sidewinder kompatibel ist und auch die halt mit den entsprechenden Legacy Interfaces äh ausgestattet äh äh wurde.
Sodass zumindest
theoretisch ich mir vorstellen kann, also die sowjetische K 13 war das so und bis heute können eben die meisten Flugzeuge russischer oder sowjetischer Bauart,
K 13 verschissen, so heißt ja also sie und ich fände es halt sehr interessant, die Frage äh so, weiß nicht, ob jemand mehr weiß, aber zumindest theoretisch nach,
müssten eigentlich ukrainische Mix und Sus auch Luftluftraketen verschießen können und
so und als russischer Pilot muss ich sagen
Ähm wie gesagt, alle Vorbehalte, dass die bisher noch im Krieg nicht wirklich zum Einsatz gekommen sind, aber zumindest aufm Papier und den Tests nach äh es
das etwas äh wo man als Pilot äh nicht sich mit auseinandersetzen möchte, wenn das auf einen,
geschossen wird, ja.
Also die Dinger äh wie gesagt in in jeder Kategorie äh so äh Intelligenz, Agilität, Wendigkeit, die haben sogar.
Also die Raketenladung
ist sogar so getimet, dass die erstmal eine schnelle Beschleunigungsphase hat, wo sie halt hm erst mal dass sie erstmal vom Flugzeug wegkommt
und dann sagen eine Orientierungsphase, wo sie etwas langsamer beschleunigt.
Und noch in der Lage ist, dann eben komplett ihre Flugrichtung,
zu ändern ohne allzu viel Energie zu verausgaben. Äh in der Zeit kann sie auch noch ein anderes Ziel erhalten, also es heißt nicht, dass sie jetzt also man kann die sozusagen auch erst abschießen und ihr dann sagen
äh wo sie hin soll und ähm kann kann sie dann auch selber erfassen, dass das Ganze ja und dann äh sagen wird,
quasi der Abbrand dieser feststoff Rakete wieder stärker, sodass sie dann halt ähm ja äh mit äh maximaler Geschwindigkeit äh dann äh ja auf das gegnerische Flug,
äh zufliegt und die Navigation ist halt auch und war früher halt super einfach, aber äh,
Ich glaube, das reicht äh an an Details, aber auf jeden Fall
diese Dinger äh ja ist so ein ist so ein Beispiel an an Hightech äh äh Waffensystem die dann ja wirklich äh
einen einen deutlichen Vorteil dann für die ukrainische Luftwaffe oder zumindest für die Luftabwehr dann auch äh äh bieten würden, weil.
Wie gesagt ähm also so richtig ja das Ding kann was.
Das Ding kann was. Zusagen sind wohl, dass es im Oktober ähm die ukrainische Armee erhalten können soll, also dieses SLM System.
Ein erstes System genau äh kostet 140 Millionen äh der der Spaß
Und äh ja besteht eben aus einem Radar-System, aus einem, wo die Raketen rauskommen.
Unten im Kontrollzentrum und einem Paket mit, ich weiß nicht, wie viel Raketen das haben sie halt nicht dazu gesagt, aber.
Weiß ich nicht. Ich denke mal so um die 100 Stück äh könnten da hoffentlich sollten damit eigentlich drin sein und 50 bis hundert,
Stück und dann sollen im Laufe der Zeit noch mehr kommen.
Ja und wie gesagt, das ist halt so ein so ein Beispiel, wo die Bundesregierung auch dazu sagt, dass es halt auf Initiative der deutschen Rüstungsindustrie und da gibt's ja halt dann eben ja,
mehrere äh.
Solche Aktionen und hier hat halt Deal Defense hat das Ding eben auf eigene Kosten entwickelt und äh ja äh also das die die SLM-Variante jetzt, nicht nicht das IST selbst, sondern.
Sagen, die S äh SLM-Variante mit eben dem dem Radarsystem und ähm ja, Waffenleitrechner und.
Antennen und Launcher und so.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, wie gesagt, dass die Dinger ziemlich fies sind, zumal eben die extreme Genauigkeit es wahrscheinlich auch ermöglicht ihm äh andere Raketen abzuschießen
und diese Fähigkeit haben ansonsten nur viel viel äh äh
teure äh ich glaube drei von den ähäh vom vom.
Eine Patriot-Variante, die äh wo jede Rakete wahrscheinlich das vier- bis Achtfache kostet so, von dem, was so eine SLM wahrscheinlich kosten wird.
Wenn man sich jetzt vorstellt, dass die ukrainische Armee mit solchen Systemen ausgerüstet wird, würde es natürlich ihre Luftabwehrfähigkeiten.
Nochmal deutlich verbessern. Derzeit läuft das ja alles mit diesen äh S drei äh hundert,
Luftabwehr äh System russischer Bauart, davon haben sie auch eine ganze Menge und die scheinen sie auch bisher sehr erfolgreich zum Einsatz gebracht haben.
Lohnfleisch jetzt mal so ein genereller Blick auch auf die Situation in der Luft, was ja.
Am Anfang dieses Krieges äh eigentlich alle gesagt haben, wovon alle Experten ausgegangen sind, dass die Russen halt innerhalb kürzester Zeit Lufthoheit äh haben müssten.
Das hat nicht stattgefunden und äh
kratzen sich da auch viele Militärs äh besonders im Westen so ein bisschen äh am Kopf, weil.
Dass auch Konsequenzen hat für die zukünftige Planung, weil grad die NATO.
Ja so eine Doktrin hat der Luft äh Überlegenheit, Lufthoheit, wie sie's im Irak gehabt haben. Alles ist darauf ausgelegt, teure Systeme, mit denen man halt äh Luftabwehr zerstören kann und dann eben
Flugzeugen alles äh in Schach halten kann
Trotzdem ist es halt der Ukraine gelungen durch geschickte Taktik ähm zwar jetzt nicht selber eine Lufthoheit herzustellen, aber sie haben zumindest es geschafft.
Zu verhindern, dass die Russen eine herstellen.
Das führt nach wie vor dazu, dass zwar Flugzeuge zum Einsatz kommen, aber das jetzt nicht,
Ansatz das definierende Element ist. Weil die Russen einfach die ganze Zeit Angst haben müssen, dass wenn sie irgendeinen Einsatz fahren, dass sie halt entweder von diesem S300 Systemen abgefangen werden oder eben von diesen vielen ähm.
Systemen, diesen abgeschossen werden, insbesondere dann, wenn sie tief fliegen, also mit dem S 3hundert verhindern sie sozusagen, dass sie hochfliegen können und wenn stattdessen fliegen sie dann relativ tief und dann sind sie natürlich angreifbar
für diese.
Wobei die.
Jetzt vorstellt, dass diese Iris T SLM äh noch dazu kommen, dann hat man natürlich erstmal noch eine sehr viel höhere Reichweite, weil die kommen irgendwie vierzig Kilometer, können die irgendwie überbrück.
Meter weit, 20 Kilometer hoch.
Und mit der Präzision, so wie du's beschrieben hast, wär's dann halt total. Das heißt, wenn da auch nur irgendeine
irgendein russisches Flugzeug in diesem Bereich unterwegs ist könnten sie halt in der Lage sein 1 nach dem anderen davon auszuknipsen.
Und äh wie gesagt die Dinger sind auch nicht so leicht leicht zu orten. Äh so äh weil die
halt dann äh gut ich weiß nicht, wie's bei dann bei der SLM genau aussieht, aber die T sucht ja selber passiv ja und schaltet halt dann erst zum Schluss äh ihr eigenes Radar nochmal ein, um halt einfach die nötige Präzision
zu haben, äh präzisere Entfernungsangaben.
So Plus hat natürlich äh äh auch die Koordinaten und äh kennt halt äh sagen auch die die
äh von dem von dem Ziel, wo das wo das gerade hinfliegt, die kriegt sie halt dann auch runtergeladen äh vom vom Flugzeug.
Und also ursprünglich habe mich dann auch mal damit beschäftigt und mich gefragt, wie funktioniert denn das?
Eigentlich jetzt, wenn die mit diesen Raketen jetzt eigentlich irgendwo hinzielen oder wird das früher funktioniert, so. Mittlerweile mit Digitaltechnik und so mit Displays kannst du einfach nur hingucken
auf das Ziel und äh dann äh auf den Knopf drücken und dann hat er das Ziel erfasst und.
Tatsächlich funktioniert das auch so mit diesen also die heißt auch Iris,
Also Iris ist auch ein schöner Name, weil ähm die hat halt äh wirklich diesen Suchkopf,
musst du dir vorstellen wirklich wie so ein bewegliches Auge, der sich so äh vorne also
klar hinter Glas, aber der sich so glaube ich fast bis 90 Grad in jede Richtung drehen kann, ja, das heißt, der der guckt also wirklich und.
Hand halt in der Mitte äh dann eben entsprechend die Auflösung. So, das heißt, der muss halt schon dann auf das Ziel gucken.
Musste früher auf das Ziel gucken, die alte Side Winder so und das heißt.
Typischerweise waren die früher eben einfach unterm Flügel montiert und guckten dann nach vorne
und dann war das Interface, was du hattest, war im Wesentlichen Audio-Interface. Die hat halt per Tonsignal dir signalisiert, äh ob sie eben jetzt das
Ziel
ähm und sagen, erfasst hat. Und was du dann eben machen musstest, weil du hat's dann im Prinzip einen Fadenkreuz oder einen einen Kreis eigentlich vorne und muss es dann,
weil die Rakete erstmal also früher guckten die halt einfach fest nach vorne und dann hast du halt äh die aktiviert
und äh dann hm hast du die halt äh das Ziel in den Kreis gebracht und hast daneben Audiofeedback äh von der äh Rakete gekriegt,
äh Soße, also diesen konstanten Ton ja und sobald du den hast äh also reicht auch äh einen einen.
Sekundenbruchteil, also muss keine bestimmte Zeit haben äh drückt man dann auf den Knopf und ab da folgt
dann dieses Auge dem Ziel, während die Rakete noch an dem Flugzeug dran ist, ja? Die hat halt ihre ihre eigene Mechanik, äh um um sich zu drehen.
Und wenn die dann abgefeuert wird,
hat die das Ziel, behält die das Ziel halt ständig diese behält das Ziel äh also behält das Auge, äh das das Ziel im Auge sozusagen äh also
im im Visier und je nachdem, wie die sich halt drehen muss, um weiter dieses,
Ziel zu tracken gibt es einerseits so 'ne Steuerinformation die das Auge bewegt aber natürlich bewegt sich die Rakete auch selbst. Die hat halt selber auch nochmal Steuerflossen ja und,
In der ursprünglichen Zeitwander ist das alles analog. Da ist kein Stück,
digital drin, was das macht, ja? Es leitet die komplett analog ins Ziel, so dass das das Tracking äh äh von dem von dem Auge und die Steuerung der
der Flossen macht da halt alles in analogrechten, aber in ist es halt eben alles digital und die kann dann auch andere Angriffsprofile.
Fliegen und es gibt auch sogar wohl eine Softwarevariante, äh die äh für Bodenziele dann geeignet ist, wo du dann halt auch mit der Eistee Bodenziele bekämpfen kannst.
Aber gut, ja, jetzt äh soll's aber auch genug sein mit Iris Tee, oder?
Ja ähm wo wir aber gerade noch bei äh.
Dem Einsatz von ähm luftbasierten Systemen sind, kann man vielleicht auch nochmal was zu den Drohnen sagen. Da war ja die Bayrak T nicht nur sehr erfolgreich, also das System aus der Türkei.
Das war ist ja äh viel besungen worden auch in der Ukraine, weil sie damit äh am Anfang sehr viele äh Erfolge erzielt haben, wohl auch immer noch tun.
Grad irgendwie glaube ich einen erfolgreichen Angriff auf so ein ähm Benzinlager oder Diesellager.
Raffinerie in äh in Russland, wo auch so eine Drohne im Anflug quasi sehr nach einer Barakta aussah und danach äh ist alles explodiert.
Ähm die Türkei hat sozusagen an der Stelle auch äh ja eine Menge schon zum Krieg beigetragen.
Ja ich hörte auch jetzt grade wohl also die.
Türken hassen die Russen. Ähm so also jetzt aus von äh jemanden der Frau Russen, die
hin, die jetzt so gerade in Moskau
war und dann über die Türkei nur reisen musste, weil es ist jetzt halt auch schwierig da hinzukommen, aber man kann halt trotzdem noch irgendwie äh hin, aber äh so über Istanbul ist halt ein Weg
so, aber die Türken sind wohl sehr unfreundlich äh zu russischen Umsteigepassagieren äh dort, dass sie dann,
auf dem äh Rückweg äh einen anderen äh Weg genommen äh hat ähm
nämlich äh dann äh was was waren das? Sie ist dann äh ich glaube über entweder über Cannoning Grad oder so was äh obenrum.
Dann dann raus.
Oder äh ja nee Sankt Petersburg glaube ich äh und dann irgendwie äh über äh mitm Zug nach Finnland rüber oder so was irgendwie.
Das hat jetzt welchen Auswirkungen auf den Krieg, dass sie äh so halt umsteigen.
Nur sozusagen die äh das war jetzt weil du sagtest sozusagen die die Türken und ihr Beitrag und sagen wie äh äh wir halt wohl auch in der türkischen Bevölkerung äh einfach,
eine eine ziemliche Antipartie äh gegen äh Russen herrscht so, dass die jetzt gerade wohl auch im Alltag einfach nur zum Ausdruck kommt.
Okay, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich mehr auf die
raus, weil ja auch amerikanische äh Drohnen in der Diskussion sind und äh auch und auch Deutschland ja in seiner neuen äh Militärrutrinen, die sich jetzt äh entwickelt äh auch im zunehmenden Maße auf Drohnen setzt. Große Rolle.
Und.
Ja und was was jetzt wohl auch war, ich meine am Anfang haben wir ja ständig irgendwelche Bilder gesehen von der Bayracta, dann wurd's aber ziemlich
ruhig darum. Äh also wir haben dann
eher weniger Bilder gesehen und der Grund war wohl, dass äh ähm Geheimhaltung vereinbart worden ist mit der Ukraine, unter anderem, weil äh sie dort,
eine ähm neue äh Art von Munition äh getestet haben in der Ukraine. Äh
die sie dann nach erfolgreichen Tests äh jetzt in die Serienproduktion überführt haben. Also insofern war die Ukraine und die Russen dann sozusagen jetzt auch
quasi Testobjekt äh für die äh neuen äh größeren äh Gleitbomben äh
für die Barata TB zwei Drohnen und ja und vermutlich ja Serienproduktion geht dann vermutlich auch als Austausch, so ein bisschen wie mit Israel und den den Impfstoffen so ja.
Heute als Testfeld bereitgestellt.
Gut, ich meine, das,
jedem Krieg so, ne? Ich meine, wenn das erste Mal alles äh im realen Einsatz kommt, dann bewähren sich natürlich bestimmte Systeme äh erst, beziehungsweise gibt es genug Gelegenheit und Anlass dann auch mal ein paar Prototypen
ins Feld zu schicken, um eine äh bereits bestehende oder neu zu startende Entwicklung dann.
Ähm auch mit aktuellen Daten zu versehen ist äh etwas wenig überraschend.
Ja, aber mittlerweile, wie gesagt, scheinen die Geheimtests abgeschlossen zu sein und jetzt sehen wir auch wieder mehr bei Racta TB zwei äh Videos.
Was ja auch wohl äh Erfolg äh gehabt hat, ist die Lieferung von den Habun äh Raketen. Die kommen aus Dänemark oder was ist Norwegen?
Ja, wir sind eigentlich, glaube ich, amerikanische Systeme, aber.
Aber ach so, die sind aber auch glaube ich von den Dänen geliefert worden oder so jetzt in die Ukraine. Mir war so. Ja stimmt, das ist von Boeing.
Genau und die sind wohl auch da und die sind jetzt wohl auch schon zum Einsatz gekommen. Und zwar auf der berühmten Stangeninsel.
Offensichtlich immer hin und her zu gehen scheint.
Also sie haben's auf jeden Fall äh zum Einsatz bringen können und haben wieder weitere äh Schiffe versenkt, irgendwelche Transporter äh Schiffe weiß ich ganz genau, was das war.
Ja einen Schlepper. Das war wohl so ein militärischer Schlepper, der äh irgendwie.
Wohl irgendwas darüber geschleppt hat um wahrscheinlich mehr Luftabwehrsysteme und Soldaten und weiß ich nicht zur Versorgung eingesetzt wurde und.
Der war wohl irgendwie mit einem Tor.
Abwehrsystem ausgestattet, hörte man. Äh was aber sie irgendwie einfach nur, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auf das Schiff draufgestellt haben
ja? Äh so ähm und es hat jedenfalls nicht funktioniert.
Ja die trotzdem getroffen und ja ähm das war ein Ding.
Ja und äh unklar ist, womit die Gasbohrinseln äh jetzt die drei in Brand geschossen wurden aktuell.
Das war auch äh eine ziemlich spektakuläre Geschichte. Das hört man natürlich jetzt nicht so gerne.
Äh wenn solche Dinge passieren, aber ja es waren wohl auch ehemals ukrainische Gasborninseln, die die Ukraine von nicht,
nicht allzu langer Zeit, also bevor äh die die Russen sie da im Rahmen der Kriminversion dann besetzt haben, haben die, glaube ich, zwei, drei Jahre vorher die gekauft.
Erst und dann haben die Russen sich die einfach unter den Nagel äh gerissen. Äh so ja.
Und jetzt sind sie halt am Brennen. Ähm ich vermute mal, äh dass das halt,
auch äh eine kleine Eskalation war Vergeltung für irgendwelche anderen Angriffe. Also man hörte, dass das wohl irgendwie Vergeltung für einen Angriff auf einen
Ukrainisches ähm,
Öl, Tanklager oder so äh wie gesagt haben, okay wenn ihr jetzt unsere Tanklager dann.
Ja
Gehen wir an eure Gasbohrinseln. Vielleicht soll das quasi auch als Abschreckung äh oder so oder als als Vergeltung ähm ja.
Ja und ähm ja wie das so mit Vergeltung ist, äh sehen, was die Russen jetzt vielleicht dann, ob sie sich davon jetzt abschrecken lassen oder selber die Vergeltung jetzt wieder vergelten, aber ja, werden sehen.
Äh wurde ja auch von Russland.
Geschworen. Ich meine, das machen sie am laufenden Meter so permanent kommentieren sie äh irgendwelche Vorgänge im Westen, Sanktionen, Maßnahmen et cetera und drohen wieder mit, ja, wir können aber auch noch
wir können alle alles total eskalieren, wo man sich immer fragt so was was wollt ihr jetzt eigentlich noch eskalieren? Ich meine ihr seid schon die maximale Eskalationsstufe in gewisser Hinsicht.
Jetzt nehme ich mal so die Gefahr eines Atomkrieges äh an der Stelle mal raus, ne. Ähm.
Ja. Mhm.
Aber so explizit gesagt haben sie es auch nicht, aber jüngster äh Anlass war das jetzt auch Litauen.
Äh stehenden Sanktionen nochmal ganz ernst genommen hat und jetzt auch die Land äh Brücke zwischen Russland und Kaliningrad.
Gekappt hat.
Na ja, nicht wirklich. Ähm.
Erstens äh bezieht sich halt äh das Ganze nur auf ungefähr 50 Prozent der Waren äh des Warenverkehrs.
Aber äh nicht auf den Personenverkehr und.
Eben nicht auf äh Waren, die nicht auf der Sanktionsliste stehen und insbesondere nicht für militärische Transporte. Die sind Gegenstand eines Sonderabkommens.
Ja, das heißt, ähm Militärzüge und Waffentransporte können auch weiterhin rein und raus. Das heißt, äh ja, die Russen kotzen natürlich jetzt, weil
Ähm das natürlich für Gardinengrad äh lang schon ein ein Problem ist und dass sie jetzt halt äh
dem Seeweg äh viele Sachen
äh liefern müssen, vor allen Dingen äh für die dortige Industrie, die halt äh ja vor allem auf auf Stahllieferungen angewiesen ist und auf energiebestimmte, weiß nicht, Energie und Rohstofflieferungen und,
die kommen halt.
Jetzt nicht mehr äh per Bahn durch, sondern die müssen jetzt irgendwie oben oben dann,
Perfekte geschickt äh werden, ja. Also mit anderen Worten, ja, es ist eine es ist eine Unbequemlichkeit für Russland, die das,
ganze verteuert und wahrscheinlich auch für die eine oder andere Knappheit äh sorgen äh wird dort aber,
äh die Russen können eigentlich nichts machen. So, was sollen sie machen? So
Ich meine, ähm das Einzige äh wäre, dass sie irgendwie ja sie können jetzt
äh den Litauern, die Einreise nach Kaliningrad verbieten, so haben sie aber noch nicht gemacht, nicht mal das
äh sozusagen nicht mal den Schrittzins jetzt gegangen, wobei es wohl sowieso nicht viele Litauer da hinzieht, insofern wäre es jetzt glaube ich auch nicht so.
Die die Katastrophe und ansonsten äh ja wie gesagt die Litauer könnten halt.
Auch noch. Also sie könnten halt wirklich äh den Verkehr unterbrechen, aber äh
Machen sie halt nicht und umgekehrt haben die Litauer jetzt auch eigentlich gar keine andere Wahl als diese Sanktionen umzusetzen, ja. Die letztlich von der EU kommen, deswegen.
Äh jetzt sozusagen dort jetzt jetzt die Litauer irgendwie rauszuziehen, macht da jetzt auch keinen Sinn.
Die Tower, den Sowjets auch gesagt, weswegen die dann wohl wiederum beim EU-Botschafter halt auch protestiert äh haben,
wer CETA und Mordio schreien aber in Wirklichkeit äh ist
Litauen halt äh hält sich an den Vertrag über den freien Personenverkehr und hält sich an den Vertrag über irgendwie den freien äh Transport für äh freien Verkehr, für Militärtransporte und äh ja.
Und was den Warenverkehr halt angeht, ja Pech gehabt. Ähm.
So aber am Ende ja äh regt sich Russland wieder synthetisch auf. Äh.
Halt.
Aber äh ja, da ist jetzt also aus meiner Sicht steckt eigentlich nicht wie gesagt, ist das nicht nicht wirklich angemessen, dass die Russen sich da jetzt
beklagen. Sowieso überhaupt nicht angemessen, dass sie sich bei irgendwas beklagen und
Ähm also bei Eskalationsmöglichkeiten gibt's halt noch eine ganze Menge, vor allem für den Westen. Ja.
Ja, der Westen. So, jetzt fragt sich natürlich, was ist denn eigentlich die Strategie des Westens? So bisher.
Scheint alles so ein bisschen
ja irgendwie wir sind dagegen und wir tun jetzt auch ein bisschen was, aber so richtig durch eskalieren wollen wir's jetzt irgendwie auch nicht. Ähm
Die Gefahr ist, dass das halt irgendwann auch über die gestiegenen Preise und so weiter, ansonsten Eskalation so der Support für die westliche Politik dahingeht.
Ja, ich meine wahrscheinlich in absoluten Dollarzahlen.
Ähm kostet der Krieg den Westen im Moment mehr äh als Russland, ja.
Also die Sanktionen äh sozusagen in absoluten Dollarbeträgen äh.
Sind wahrscheinlich so für den für den Westen irgendwie mehrere Milliarden pro Tag an äh,
nicht stattgefunden im Wachstum oder an weniger Bruttoinlandsprodukt ähm und bei den Russen.
So äh sind es äh so rechnet man zwischen 10 und 20 Prozent deren Bruttoinlandsprodukts oder
ich sage mal 300 Millionen pro Tag direkte Kriegskosten und nochmal zwischen 500 und 700 Millionen pro Tag an Sanktionskosten so. Das heißt, Russland
Sanktionen plus plus Krieg im Moment eine Milliarde am Tag
wahrscheinlich mehrere Milliarden äh an entgangenem Wachstum, also Deutschland alleine nur hat glaube ich pro Tag 200 Millionen äh höhere
ja also Deutschland alleine äh ungefähr 200 Millionen am Tag an wie weniger Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Äh wegen höherer Energiekosten.
Ja und wenn du das dann alles hochrechnest, wie gesagt, kommst du, also allein Deutschland kommst du halt insgesamt eben beim Westen auf mehrere Milliarden, aber relativ gesehen natürlich ähm ich meine.
Der Westen sage ich mal, ich habe bisher immer nur die NATO gerechnet, aber äh wenn du jetzt noch die Länder wie Japan dazu zählst oder Südkorea oder andere,
die faktisch äh ja äh nicht zur NATO gehören, aber auch irgendwo dem westlichen Block nahestehen und eben auch äh ihn unterstützen.
Dann reden wir von 1,4 Milliarden Menschen
Das ist äh zehnmal so viel Bevölkerung wie Russland hat. Und was auch viele nicht wissen oder zumindest mir, was nicht klar ist, äh dass die Sowjetunion,
fast doppelt so viele äh Bürger hatte wie Russland äh heutzutage noch hat, ja? Das heißt äh
Russland ist nur die Hälfte der Sowjetunion und ähm ja äh und wenn man dann das eben auch noch vergleicht äh wiederum mit ja dem dem Westen.
Der dann ungefähr mit 50.000 Milliarden, also über 50.0000 Milliarden, 31 Mal so hohes Bruttoinlandsprodukt. Äh hat wie Russland, ja. Das heißt,
wenn Russland jetzt äh wirklich,
auf maximale Kriegsproduktion schaltet, so wie im Zweiten Weltkrieg. Ja,
andere Länder das gemacht haben, also Deutschland oder England. Äh die sind dann
so in ihrem Maximum äh haben diese Länder zwischen 15 und 60Prozent ihres Bruttoinlandsprodukts für den Krieg aufgewendet. So, wenn Russland das tun würde, so käme halt vielleicht 700 Milliarden
pro Jahr
zusammen jetzt sagt man Kaufkraft bereinigt, Faktor drei ungefähr könnte Russland also sozusagen maximal aus eigener Kraft irgendwie 200 Milliarden pro Jahr,
für Rüstung bereitstellen. Das wäre ungefähr was der BIP mit 4äh der Westen mit 4 Prozent seines Bruttoinlandsprodukts kontern könnte und würde halt
im Prinzip ähm.
Ähm seine Rüstungsausgaben äh damit absolut ähm ja äh was wären das auf auf sechstausend Milliarden.
Äh äh letztlich.
Steigern, ja? Also wenn einer auf 200 Milliarden verdreifachen so, äh um sagen so rum,
also wenn Russland alles für den Krieg aufwenden würde, ähm.
Könnte der Westen mit 4 Prozent oder 2000 Milliarden äh dagegen halten, ja.
Und äh wäre aber in der Lage natürlich, wenn's wirklich drauf ankommt, dann äh ja auch auf äh
fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, zehn Prozent äh eben mal hochzugehen, ja, wenn's wenn's denn unbedingt sein müsste. Also mit anderen Worten
so wenn solange dem Westen nicht der Willen ausgeht hat
Russland äh einfach dem nichts entgegenzusetzen auf Dauer.
Weshalb es eigentlich auch fast egal ist, äh wie die Ukraine jetzt äh ob äh da irgendwie mal fünf oder zehn Kilometer oder irgendwie eine 100tausend Einwohnerstadt.
Dann äh ja in russische Hände fällt.
Spielt keine Rolle, selbst wenn die Russen die Halbukraine ein äh nehmen würden, ja. Äh die Deutschen haben die ganze Ukraine eingenommen im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Es hat am Ende ja nicht nicht geklappt so,
Insofern ist äh in diesem Konflikt äh jetzt äh sind diese kleineren,
oder Frontbewegungen sind jetzt nicht wirklich relevant, ähm sondern eigentlich eher kann man festhalten, dass die Ukraine.
Einer gewaltigen äh Übermacht äh äh dort äh.
Standhält, ja und ähm so äh ja für die für die Russen einfach äh das.
Was sie da bisher rein äh gegeben haben, sich das definitiv nicht ausgezahlt hat und sich auch auf absehbare Zeit äh,
ja, nicht nicht rechnen.
Die Frage ist, rechnen die Russen so und wie rechnet der Westen? Ich meine, das ist jetzt sozusagen eine Betrachtung der Kosten,
Das ist ja das eine. Das äh die Betrachtung der Kosten derzeit, ne und die eigentliche Rechnung ist ja, was kostet uns das, äh wenn die Russen hier ihr ihr Spiel durchziehen?
Äh und wie gesagt äh.
Die Russen, also das war jetzt sozusagen so eine so eine Grenzwertbetrachtung, kann man sagen. Was ist, wenn die Russen wirklich jetzt den totalen Krieg erklären?
Würden. So ähm.
Und äh gut, äh auch noch mal müssen wir, glaube ich, in jeder äh Sendung auch noch dazu sagen, was ist mit den Atomwaffen? Kommt da natürlich der Einwand und ähm.
Ja Atomwaffen sind nutzlos.
Äh also der einzige Nutzen, den Atomwaffen haben, ist äh zu verhindern, dass jemand andere Atomwaffen gegen dich einsetzt. Ja, das ist sozusagen der einzige Nutzen, aber du kannst ihn nicht selber einsetzen, nicht wirklich.
So, du kannst nicht mal dann Leute damit erpressen als Staat so. Auch das funktioniert halt nicht. Selbst wenn der andere keine Atomwaffen hat,
weil ich meine, die Russen äh sagen können ja auch nicht hingehen und jetzt sagen irgendwie also Ukraine, kapituliere jetzt, äh weil wir haben Atomwaffen. Legt jetzt eure Waffen nieder, ja?
Äh nee, geht halt nicht. So wie die Amerikaner halt äh ihre Atomwaffen im Vietnamkrieg völlig nutzlos waren und überhaupt her, wie gesagt, Atomwaffen sind halt völlig nutzlos.
Weil man sie halt nicht einsetzen kann.
Okay, kleiner kleiner Abstecher zu den Atomkraftwerken äh zu den Atomwaffen. Ähm hat mir glaube ich in der letzten Sendung äh oder in der vorletzten.
Hatten wir in den letzten, aber das kam.
Ja muss man muss man halt aber glaube ich auch auf immer wieder äh wiederholen, weil äh also man kann diese Atomdrohung der Russen einfach nicht nicht ernst nehmen, ja.
Aber äh ja, deswegen braucht man da auch nicht nicht lange drüber zu reden. Das ist halt ja äh sind halt nutzlos in dem Konflikt.
Also der Westen hat keine Strategie, sagst du.
Na ja, äh genau, das habe ich mich dann äh jetzt gefragt, okay, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich die Strategie des Westens oder oder hat er eine und äh.
Im Moment könnte man die Strategie vielleicht so beschreiben, ja
äh erstmal verhindern, äh dass die Russen irgendwie gewinnen und sie eben zu Schwächen und äh sie möglichst irgendwie zu demütigen und davon abzuhalten
äh jemals
wieder so etwas äh zu versuchen, ja und ihn vor allen Dingen äh keine Gewinne zu erlauben, also am Ende, dass sie irgendetwas äh äh,
behalten dürfen oder irgendwie einen Lohn dafür kriegen, dass es sozusagen jetzt das das Ziel und die Strategie,
ist jetzt das äh ja vermutlich irgendwie durch Abnutzung äh zu erreichen. Äh gerade. Aber,
da äh habe ich halt ähm einen sehr schönen.
Artikel gefunden beziehungsweise stand in einem in einem Buch auch ähm von einem von einem amerikanischen Autor, der.
Dann meinte äh vor allem im Hinblick auf den Vietnamkrieg, wo die Amerikaner ja auch quasi Abnutzungsstrategie gefahren haben. Wir bombardieren jetzt äh,
ähm die dauernd und äh ja gucken und bis bis sie halt aufgeben und der meint eben ja, aber Abnutzung ist halt keine Strategie, sondern äh auf Abnutzung
zu setzen. So ist eigentlich das Eingeständnis, äh dass man
grade keine Alternative hat und es ist halt einfach militärisch absolut
unprofessionell und äh benutzt halt eben Blut anstelle von Hirn. Äh so. Ja
Also Abnutzung so heißt halt ja,
man kann halt nix wirklich tun grade. So also es ist eben genau keine Strategie. So auf der anderen Seite,
ähm äh musst du natürlich auch sagen, ja, es ist nun mal so die Situation, die Ukrainer haben.
Mit dem, was sie was sie äh haben an an Fähigkeiten und Möglichkeiten so ähm.
Mehr geleistet, mehr geschafft, als man ihnen jemals zugetraut.
Ja haben also alle Erwartungen äh in in in aller Welt übertroffen äh so.
Von dem äh was sie geschafft haben und äh das bedeutet aber nicht, dass sie jetzt plötzlich irgendwie auch noch die Kraft haben
auch noch die nötige Übermacht oder die Überlegenheit auf einmal aufzubauen, um jetzt in in kürzester Zeit
dann gegen offensiven unternehmen zu können, sondern da äh müssen sie erstmal nicht nur Parität äh erreichen mit den Russen, äh sondern tatsächlich auch umgekehrt dann äh wirklich eine eine Übermacht.
Hinbekommen und.
Da ist eben das das Problem, das ich gerade sehe, wie gesagt, Abnutzung ist halt keine Strategie, weil das kann eben ewig dauern und,
am Ende äh muss eine Seite in die Lage versetzt werden an Boden zu gewinnen, ja.
So und eigentlich kann das nur die Ukraine sein und es ist dann halt ein bisschen unklar, warum man sich dort jetzt zurückhält.
Da heißt es dann ja stimmen auch wir dürfen Russland nicht demütigen aber
eben bis hin zu wiederum anderen. Sie sagen, oh Russland muss in der Ukraine unbedingt gedemütigt werden, ja? Also äh Russland braucht es einfach, weil die Sowjetunion wurde offensichtlich noch nicht genug gedemütigt.
Oder hat nicht die nötige äh äh Demut aufgebracht, selber zu erkennen.
Äh dass der Untergang der Sowjetunion auch völlig selbstverschuldet war, ja.
Und äh nicht irgendwie, das war jetzt nicht der böse Westen, sondern die haben sich halt einfach selber
zu Grunde gewirtschaftet, ja? Mit Korruption und Diebstahl und Misswirtschaft und und allem, ja, am Anfang mag ja der Kommunismus äh noch einen Fortschritt gewesen sein gegenüber dem Zahnreich.
Aber äh dann irgendwann äh ja.
Ging's halt so nicht mehr weiter so und das war nicht die Schuld des Westens. Dass es nicht weiterging, sondern ähm war weniger, dass der Westen jetzt den Kalten Krieg gewonnen hat, sondern Russland hat
einfach äh sich zusammengefaltet.
Ja ohne dass da irgendjemand jetzt groß was reinbomben musste oder von außen irgendwie noch noch groß für Unruhe sorgen, sondern dass ja das war einfach äh von selbst instabil so.
Und so sieht es eben auch mit
Der Rest Sowjetunion nahmen Soßland aus und wahrscheinlich muss die wirklich auch irgendwie nochmal ja.
Und zerfallen beziehungsweise ähm ja äh zumindest einfach mal eine eine Kehrtwende
äh eine eine Bewusstseinskehrtwende eintreten und ohne Demütigung scheint es halt dann äh nicht nicht machbar zu sein. Zu erkennen, dass sie eben nicht mehr Supermacht sind so.
Und das Problem ist eigentlich, dass sie versuchen sich wie eine Supermacht aufzuführen, aber mit ja,
40 Millionen Einwohnern, da schrumpfenden Bevölkerung und äh ja ihrem Bruttoinlands äh Produkt.
Äh so zählt einfach äh nicht. Also reicht nicht für Supermacht.
Haben sie auch die industriellen Kapazität einfach überhaupt nicht. Äh eigentlich ist das nur so ein ja so ein äh Handelsladen für äh natürliche Ressourcen.
Ja, also die haben halt wir auch Venezuela so haben halt eben auch den Fluch des des Öls. So das ist halt
auch so ein Ding, also lohnt sich auch mal Geschichte von Venezuela müsste man vielleicht auch auch mal irgendwann was zu machen, aber wie wie Venezuela durch Öl
äh zum Reichsten Land,
äh und dann fast zum ärmsten Land äh der Welt wurde, alles durch durch Öl. Und nicht weil ihnen das Öl ausgegangen wäre, sondern weil einfach äh
Dieser ölreichtum einfach dieses Land strukturell komplett zerstört hat, ja? Strukturell und wirtschaftlich, so.
Und äh ja und das ist trifft eben auch auf auf Russland äh zu. Russland ist einfach ein kaputtes Land und schuld daran ist eben auch das Öl.
Und und Gas. Ja. Und ähm insofern ja vielleicht wenn dann auch irgendwann Öl und Gas.
Äh dann nicht mehr die die Rolle spielen. Ähm werden auch eben diese Länder sich überlegen.
Dass sie irgendwas Sinnvolles auch äh also dass sie halt auch irgendwie arbeiten müssen, um um Geld
zu verdienen, ja und irgendwie was Sinnvolles herstellen und nicht nur irgendwie äh Dinge ausm Boden.
Äh die.
Dort seit vielen Millionen Jahren rumgelegen haben und dann einfach weg sind. So dass es nicht äh ja äh wie ein Land auf Dauer funktionieren kann.
Ja aber nichtsdestotrotz ähm so das Thema Sanktionen ähm ist mir nochmal.
Bewusst geworden. Äh habe ich ja erzählt, als ich jetzt neulich für ein paar Tage in Moldawien war.
Und das war dann auch nochmal eine sehr interessante Perspektive, weil Moldawien ist eine äh nicht nicht ganz die erste ehemalige Sowjetrepublik
die ich besucht habe. Ich war früher auch schon mal in Estland, aber habe generell so mich.
Eher zurückgehalten, so mit mit
Osten und und und Russland besuchen, das war mir alles nicht so geheuer auch und ich mag halt einfach so hochgerupte Länder nicht.
So, das ist mir, die möchte ich halt auch nicht unterstützen, wenn dann quasi so Grundfunktionen äh des Staates nicht erfüllt werden, ohne dass man dann Leute schmiert. Das kann ich nicht haben, ja.
Das mag ich nicht und ja, das dazu gehört halt Russland. Aber ja.
Moldawien erstmal äh du warst noch nicht da, nehme ich an, ne. Das hättest du mir sonst gesagt. Ähm ja.
Unglaublich tolles Land. Ähm.
So tolle Leute, großartiger Wein, also die besten Weine der Welt unlogen ohne Übertreibung und äh auch wirklich hervorragendes Essen.
Und ja halbwegs umgängliche Leute.
Da ein paar nette Freundschaften auch äh geschlossen. Ähm.
Mir dann eben auch erzählen lassen unter anderem, wie denn die Leute das dort
erlebt haben und ja so ein paar Dinge sind vielleicht interessant, dass natürlich dort
denen auch in den ersten Tagen, als der Krieg losging, wirklich der Arsch auf Grundeis ging, weil und sie erwarteten natürlich.
Dass die Russen dann,
einfach durchmarschieren und äh sich ja auch Moldawien äh wieder einverleiben, dass.
Sie dann natürlich erst so Transnistrien so erreichen und äh dort, wo halt auch russische Truppen stationiert sind und viele Waffen.
Gelagert sind und dass sie dann gleich weitermarschieren und dann eben auch äh sich Moldawien wieder einverleiben.
Und deswegen sah es dann wohl jeder den ganzen Tag äh auf hing in irgendwelchen Telegram-Channels.
Und jede Minute, jede neue Nachricht wurde dann halt geteilt und äh ja, also alle waren erstmal wirklich kirre.
Aber äh ja im Laufe der Wochen, äh als dann man gemerkt hat, okay, in die Russen kommen halt doch nicht so richtig äh vorbei, haben die Leute sich dann wieder etwas entspannt.
Und zum Thema Transnistrien.
Auch vorausschicken bis hin zur Geschichte, also Moldawien war auch lange Zeit Teil von Rumänien, also bildet mit wie drei anderen Republiken äh oder drei anderen ja.
Wie auch immer, dann äh Republik Rumänien.
Und äh war dann eben auch mal äh wiederum um russischer und russischer Kontrolle auch und äh wurde dann aber nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg dann hat die Sowjetunion sich das Ganze einverleibt.
Und hm als ich dann gefragt habe, ja wie ist denn das jetzt mit Transnistrien und so? Gibt's da irgendwie Spannungen deswegen und war ich erstmal überrascht zu hören? Also irgendwie.
Die Moldaria also mit Transnistrien.
Das hat eigentlich eh nie zu wirklich zu uns gehört, sondern das war Teil der Ukraine. So.
Ja, das heißt äh da war dann, als es dann, ich glaube, zweiundneunzig oder dreiundneunzig diesen Aufstand gab.
Waren die dann auch gar nicht so jetzt erbost da darüber oder so. Hm.
Dass dass sich dieses Transnistrieren dann dann selbstständig gemacht hat und gut, dann wurden dort russische Friedenstruppen stationiert, die dort bis heute sind, die dann verhindern sollten, dass es irgendwie zu ethnischen Unruhen kommt.
Und hm ansonsten hat dieses Transnistrien halt eine eigene Grenze, wobei,
auf äh ja auf transnistischer Seite. Also im Grunde genommen
das Transnistrien ist halt sozusagen alles, was hinter dem, hinter dem Fluss ist, wobei hm,
tatsächlich auch Teile
auf der östlichen Seite des Flusses äh noch nicht offiziell Transnistrien äh sind und ähm,
Da leben auch ungefähr ist nicht ein Drittel Russen und ein Drittel Ukrainer und ein Drittel Moldavia und auch noch Bulgaren und Deutsche lebten da auch mal.
Aber die wurden glaube ich alle alle vertrieben und auf jeden Fall war das sowieso immer irgendwie so ein so ein so ein Mix und.
Was mir dann auch nochmal klar geworden ist, dadurch ähm.
Gefragt, wieso haben die Sowjets dann aber diesen Teil der Ukraine dann Moldawien zugeschlagen? So was sollte das dann? Und vermutlich war's derselbe Grund, warum
sie die Krim der Ukraine zugeschlagen haben innerhalb der Sowjetunion, nämlich um.
Halt in diesen Republiken oder Subjekten oder wie auch immer.
Dass dann dort mehr Russen sind, also quasi so eine Art, wenn du willst, so in so einem pro russisches Jerry Mentoring haben Sie da betrieben, ja?
Um ja dann auch die die Länder quasi zu russifizieren und dann dort mehr Russen äh äh an anzusiedeln und äh äh gegebenenfalls der die eigene
Identität dieser Länder zu untermauern. Und unter dem Aspekt hatte ich das halt noch nicht gesehen
Und als dann natürlich aber die Sowjetunion jetzt auseinandergefallen sind bei oh die armen Russen und die
Krim gehört hier eigentlich zu denen und die Sowjets haben ja nur aus formalen Gründen dann äh das Ganze
dann die die Krim,
an die Ukraine geben? Nee, nee, das waren keine formalen Gründe, sondern das war ich sage mal, eine äh eine Maßnahme der Zwangsrossifizierung und wenn man das unter dem Aspekt
sieht, finde ich, wäre es auch moralisch absolut die gerechte Strafe.
Äh so äh für diese Rossifizierung, äh wenn äh am Ende die Krim äh dann äh zur Ukraine geht und die Russen äh
da ja das Nachsehen haben, zumal es für die EU für die Russen dort wahrscheinlich eh besser wäre ähm.
Wenn sie äh ukrainische Staatsbürger sind als als Russisch.
Brauchst du sicherlich auch für den Donbass gilt.
Also ich glaube, da bereuen das äh gerade auch ganz viele Leute, wobei eben viele Leute auch einfach gar nicht die Wahl haben, ja so richtig.
Oder äh eigentlich nur die Wahl haben, entweder äh irgendwo zu zu fliehen oder äh sich und da da hat nicht nicht jeder ist halt so drauf, dass er sagt, ich,
Ja, ich verlasse jetzt meine Heimat
oder sich dann der Rekrutierung äh zu zu widersetzen
dort und da wurden ja eben die die ganzen Großteil der männlichen Bevölkerung da ja im im Donbass äh äh wurde ja eben zum Militär dann zwangsrekrutiert.
Was mir dann aber klar wurde auch noch also gut sie hatten auch eine eine größere Flüchtlingswelle aus der Ukraine, also einer der Freunde, die ich da kennengelernt habe, der hatte dann auch äh so zweimal.
Ukrainische Familien bei sich. Die haben auch dann alle geholfen, aber die sind dann entweder weitergezogen, äh aber gleichzeitig sind auch.
Jetzt dort viele ja ähm wohlhabende Russen und äh Ukrainer äh sind jetzt auch in in Moldawien und insgesamt,
obwohl es sich um eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt nicht der Welt Europas äh handelt,
ja lässt es sich dort gut leben, so.
Und ich kann auch äh für jeden den Besuch nur empfehlen, der irgendwie gerne interessantes, neues Essen und guten Wein äh genießen möchte. Ich glaube, äh so äh ja Moldawien kann das,
Geld auch ganz gut gebrauchen und äh ja es ist alles da äh haben ihr schönes Trollybusnetz im Übrigen äh in in,
Kisenau ähm so recht gute Luft
äh auch dort in der in der ganzen Stadt, weil es auch einfach wenig Industrie gibt. Das ist wohl der der Grund die größten Weinkeller der Welt mit
Bis zu 20 Millionen Flaschen sind da glaube ich gelagert. Äh Rebsorten, von denen man noch nicht gehört hat landschaftlich durchaus auch attraktiv.
So ja also.
Mit anderen Worten, ja, kann man, kann man.
Oder musstest du da irgendwie umsteigen?
Über Österreich, über Wien äh so also äh ist natürlich auch bisschen schwieriger geworden, aber ja also.
Über Wien und ansonsten ja die Leute sprechen dort halt rumänisch. Das heißt offiziell moldarisch, aber äh so es gibt halt keinen Unterschied zwischen Moldawisch und rumänisch äh so sagen die Leute.
Und es gibt halt deswegen auch eine große Nähe zu Rumänien und insofern wäre halt ein EU-Beitritt äh so äh also es gibt
gibt ohnehin eine extreme Nähe äh dort viele Moldawier studieren in Rumänien zum Beispiel, weil es natürlich auch keine Sprachbarriere gibt,
äh dort äh sondern äh ja das bestenfalls einen leicht Tag Unterschied im Akzent ist. Ähm.
Und äh ja insofern also wir Moldawien auch eine schöne Bereicherung äh für die EU, glaube ich. Und äh.
Ja jetzt auch offiziell den Kandidatenstatus äh genauso wie die Ukraine verliehen bekommen im Gegensatz zu Georgien.
Insofern wird das jetzt zumindest offiziell angestrebt, wobei man dazu sagen muss, dieser Kandidatenstatus, von dem er immer die Rede ist, der ist
so in der europäischen Verfassung nicht äh klar benannt. Also das ist sozusagen eher so eine
politische Umschreibung einer Grundhaltung, aber es ist jetzt hat keine unmittelbaren rechtlichen Konsequenzen.
Ja und der eigentliche Punkt war ähm dass.
Sagen, wenn eines der ärmsten.
Länder Europas was wo die Leute ein deutlich niedrigeres Durchschnittseinkommen noch haben als in Russland zum Beispiel. Ähm ja da lässt sich's leben, ja so,
und da ist mir dann klar geworden, dass Russland äh
ja noch eine also dass der Weg nach unten äh ganz schön weit ist. Ja für für Russland so. Das also,
den Sanktionen und die 10 bis20Prozent äh vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt ja, das ist auf der einen Seite natürlich katastrophal, aber auf der anderen Seite weiß man halt auch aus der Sowjetzeit.
Wie lange im Ostblock eben viel Infrastruktur einfach auf auf Verschleißgefahren wurde und wie lange das das gut geht, ja, bevor
es dann endgültig kollabiert. Insofern waren dann wenn ich immer gefragt werde, ja wie lange dauert denn der Krieg jetzt noch und ich dann sage, na ja
Also höchstens 20 Jahre.
Basierend auf, na ja, dass die Amerikaner 20 Jahre in Afghanistan waren oder ja.
Koalition und die Russen halt immerhin zehn Jahre äh dort verbracht. Haben so insofern,
ich hoffe nicht, dass das so lange geht, aber äh ausschließend kann man das halt auch nicht, dass ich das zu einem wirklich sehr langen äh Konflikt.
Äh entwickelt, der dann so dahin plätschert.
Also 20 Jahre werden wir jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu lang.
Absolut und wie gesagt, ich denke auch nicht äh also bei der bei der Intensität, aber ähm ja so schnell äh sieht es nicht aus, dass das dass das Ganze zu Ende sein könnte.
Letztlich muss man sich, glaube ich, klarmachen.
So ein bisschen meinen Eindruck gerade und derzeit wehrt sich natürlich äh alles in uns und äh so in Europa an sich gegen diesen Gedanken, aber muss ich sozusagen schon klar machen, dass eigentlich.
Wir im Krieg sind mit Russland.
Wir sind nicht in so einem heißen Krieg, aber der der kalte Krieg ist auf jeden Fall gut aufgewärmt.
Und äh auch wenn's ein Stellvertreterkrieg ist, ist es trotzdem.
Ein Krieg und äh wird bedeuten, dass wir in gewisser Hinsicht uns in den nächsten Jahren vermutlich.
Ja zumindest teilweise auf so.
Industrielle Zeiten einstellen müssen, wo sehr viel mehr Geld ins Militär geht äh einfach um der Ukraine mindestens die Gelegenheit zu geben, die Stellungen zu halten beziehungsweise eben im Idealfall.
Auch den Spieß umzudrehen.
Und wie gesagt, unten im Wirtschaftskrieg, der tatsächlich wahrscheinlich sogar größere Schäden verursacht als äh der heiße Krieg, sind wir ja sogar direkter Teilnehmer, ja. So da,
gibt's ja noch nicht mal Stellvertreter, sondern das geht ja direkt äh gegen Russland und Russland gegen uns.
Mit. Gut, natürlich jetzt den auch Drosselung der Gaslieferung, die wir noch nicht erwähnt haben.
Ähm ja äh war zu erwarten wird man sehen wie weit das noch geht. Im Moment,
glaube ich eher, dass die Russen halt Spielchen spielen, weil
Ähm so die Tanks sind jetzt halb gefüllt irgendwie, aber sie wollen jetzt möglichst, dass wir die nicht zu voll machen äh unsere Gastanks äh wiederum äh damit,
sie mehr Druckpotenzial haben, aber ja man wird sehen, müssen wir halt durch. So.
Hilft halt nix. Ja für für ich mein für Russland geht's natürlich jetzt mittlerweile wirklich.
Seine zukünftige Position und Respekt in der Welt und da sieht's halt gerade nicht gut aus, auch nicht unter Freunden. Also China ist nicht begeistert.
Indien ist nicht begeistert. Äh viele der Nachbarländer äh und ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken kotzen auch richtig ab.
Ähm gerade und ja so richtig.
Rennt grad niemand in der Welt äh rum und applaudiert den den Russen oder äh ja äh oder wenn, weiß ich nicht.
Wie es mit euch ich glaube selbst Nordkorea hat irgendwie äh kritische Worte geäußert, aber äh.
Na gut, der deren Wort spielt jetzt, glaube ich, grade nicht so eine große Rolle, aber,
du erwähnt hast, ist ganz interessant. Damit habe ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht gerechnet. Äh es gibt ja noch diesen Sicherheitsverbund, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie der äh heißt so, äh wo halt äh Russland, Weißrussland.
Auch noch ein paar angrenzende äh weitere Staaten wie Kasachstan dabei sind
Und na ja und solche äh Länder, wo man denken würde, okay, die hängen noch so sehr äh an Russland dran und haben so viel zu verlieren. Die positionieren sich aber doch relativ klar, also gerade Kasachstan so
sagt einfach so, ja, nee, das werden wir nicht anerkennen und äh finden das nicht gut. Ich weiß nicht, intern wird da sicherlich noch ein bisschen mit härteren Bandagen diskutiert, aber das finde ich schon ziemlich bemerkenswert, dass die sich da so überhaupt äh positionieren.
Und gut natürlich auch gut Georgien sowieso äh ja ähm.
Konnte da auch, also ist dort auch so ein kulturelles äh Ding und es die haben auch einen Wein aufgelegt in Moldawien.
Den sogenannten Freedom Blend
einer der größten äh ja und der besteht halt aus Rebsorten so aus Moldawien äh der Ukraine und aus Georgien. Den haben die halt seit 2014 gibt's den halt.
Ja auch ganz guter Wein.
Wobei äh ich dort auch Bessere gefunden habe, aber die Idee äh fand ich irgendwie auch interessant, gibt's in jedem Supermarkt in Frieden blend. So.
Ja ein weiterer interessanter Punkt war natürlich, dass äh
jetzt für russische Rüstungsexporte, die Aussichten auch eher schlecht sind. Da wird wohl eher dann jetzt in den nächsten Jahren äh der äh Weltmarktanteil der Russen weiter deutlich
zurückgehen und ähm das ist halt.
Auch ein gewisses Problem, weil äh natürlich auch teilweise die eigene
Rüstungsindustrie oder das Überleben der eigenen Rüstungsindustrie auch ein Stück weit von Rüstungsexporten einfach abhängt, aber,
Ja, moderne Waffen waren halt bisher weitgehend so ein No-Show in der Ukraine, also die deren ganze Superwaffen, wie weiß ich nicht, der
T einundvierzig äh ET 4zehn Amata äh zum Beispiel hat man nicht gesehen, weil's einfach auch nicht genug davon gibt und der wahrscheinlich nicht nicht einsatz äh reif ist, genauso.
Dann äh die modernsten äh Kampfflugzeuge und so.
Hat man noch nicht gesehen, wahrscheinlich aus Angst, dass die dann dort abgeschossen werden und dann noch weniger Nachfrage finden, dann ist natürlich jetzt die Produktion moderner Waffen durch Sanktionen am ehesten
und äh ja außerdem wird Russland halt auch gar keine wohlfreie und eine Kapazitäten für,
Produktion haben, also mit anderen Worten äh könnte Russland auch einen fast einen Totalausfall dann auf dem,
Markt der Rüstungsgüter werden nur so als interessante Randnotiz.
Weil sie gar nichts mehr produziert bekommen als so.
Ja, äh wie gesagt, aus den verschiedenen Gründen. Erstens.
Weil sie keine freien Kapazitäten für Exportproduktion äh haben werden bis auf Weiteres und äh von den Sanktionen halt äh betroffen sind und weil aber auch niemand, deren Waffen so richtig haben.
Werden wollen wird. So, das ist sozusagen das andere Problem, weil die halt jetzt bisher nicht so richtig überzeugt haben.
Dortmund Indien ist äh eins der größeren Länder, die äh sich ganz ordentlich bisher bei den Russen bedient haben und nicht so sehr auf amerikanische äh Technik gesetzt haben.
Ja, aber bei den bei den modernen Jets haben sie auch erstmal Nett gesagt, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Sie haben auch äh eine Bestellung äh zurückgenommen von Kampfhubschraubern, die äh eigentlich anstanden, das ist schon vor einiger Zeit äh passiert.
Wo, glaube ich, die die Triebwerke irgendwie nicht ordentlich funktionierten.
Ob das wirklich einen technischen Grund hatte oder ob das sozusagen äh jetzt auch politische Gründe hatte in irgendeiner Form.
Nee, ich glaube, es war halt hauptsächlich das einige Länder eben ja von der äh äh eben Qualität und Performance noch nicht überzeugt äh waren und äh meinten, dass viel von dem noch nicht so richtig ausgereift ist.
Oder Qualitätsmängel hat. Ja.
Ja das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Schlag. Im Energiebereich denke ich mal äh haben sie noch genug Möglichkeiten, das äh Öl, was jetzt der West nicht annimmt, das äh nimmt gerade China äh danken zum Discountpreis äh an.
Damit retten sie sozusagen den Russen auch ihre Produktionsstätten, weil das ist ja quasi die Gefahr, dass wenn das Öl nicht abgenommen wird, dass sie dann äh,
Weil sie das nicht zwischenlagern können, weil sie nicht die,
Kapazitäten haben, wenn sie es nicht loswerden, müssen sie halt ihre äh Ölquellen zurückfahren und wenn die einmal zurückgefahren sind, dann lassen die sich auch gar nicht so einfach wieder hochfahren.
Na ja. Man wird, wird sehen. So, wie gesagt, bisher auf jeden Fall äh ja.
Ähm sind die Sanktionen oder im Vergleich so zwischen heißt immer Tenks versus Bangs äh so äh liegen die Tanks gerade bisher noch vorne,
So und äh ja äh so und die Bands ja ähm.
Gesagt haben noch keine sichtbaren äh Erfolge erzielt.
Das ist auch eher mittel- und langfristig, denke ich mal.
Naja, es hieß dann so, oh mein Gott, äh also vor drei Monaten hieß es eigentlich, ja, aber spätestens im Juni äh so äh werden die Auswirkungen der Sanktionen katastrophal sein für Russland und
davon ist bisher aber äh noch nicht so richtig äh zu merken und ich werde mal hören
Ende.
Am Wochenende bin ich vielleicht länger mit einem äh mit jemandem zusammen, der gerade in Moskau war und mir vielleicht ein bisschen mehr erzählen kann, wie es da
gerade so aussieht, aber äh zumindest was ich so bisher vernommen habe, äh scheint dort alles noch zu funktionieren.
Weitgehend. So, also so Störung, also größere Störungen im öffentlichen Leben oder so wurden mir jetzt nicht berichtet. Es ist halt alles teurer geworden.
Oder vieles ist teurer geworden. Ja und wohl die und die Leute äh,
sind haben's wohl alle sehr eilig nach Hause zu kommen von der Arbeit.
Also das öffentliche Leben ist auch so ein bisschen ja Leute haben nicht so richtig viel Lust sich draußen rumzutreiben.
Gut, lass uns äh zum Ende äh äh kommen. Vielleicht ein kurzer Ausblick, womit wir jetzt so äh rechnen in der aktuellen Situation?
Militärischen Lager haben wir ja zusammengefasst. Wir haben die ganzen Rahmenbedingungen
zusammengefasst und es ist davon auszugehen, dass dieser Abnutzungskrieg, so wie er derzeit stattfindet, ohne größere nennenswerte Änderungen der Gesamtsituation noch eine Weile so weitergehen kann. Es kann
sehr gut sein, dass die Russen es in irgendeiner Form schaffen, da an dieser Ostfront
paar äh Erfolge zu erzielen, die nicht so schön sind. Man muss schauen, wie sich das ukrainische Militär dann verhält. Das ist ja immer so die Frage, inwiefern
heizt man jetzt die eigenen Ressourcen oder ist es dann nicht sinnvoller sich dann doch nochmal aus einem Bereich zurückzuziehen?
Und was ja auch sozusagen dann auch im Raum steht, ist dass alle auch mal eine Pause brauchen. Das gilt also vor allem auch für die Russen.
Die sich grade da total äh verausgaben. Die haben einfach äh extreme Verluste
Jetzt kämpfen sie wahrscheinlich noch äh bis sie eben dieses äh Stilviro äh Donezk äh kriegen und dann
Wahrscheinlich auch erstmal in sich gehen müssen, aber so eine Pause,
Pause ist natürlich ein großes Wort. Es wird irgendwie weiter gekämpft werden, aber vielleicht nicht mehr in solchen, in so einer massiven Schlachtfilm in einem bestimmten Zeitraum.
So eine Pause weiß man auch nicht, was die Folge davon ist, weil letzten Endes natürlich beide Seiten Zeit gewinnen. Die Ukraine könnte das gut gebrauchen, einfach um mal ihre Kapazität
äh aufzustocken und all das ganze Gerät, was ihnen zugesagt wurde in Stellung zu bringen, aber das gilt natürlich dann auch genauso für die Russen, die sich tiefer eingraben und dann eben auch die Bereiche, die sie bisher eingenommen haben
besser verteidigen können.
Also das ist genau also insofern läuft alles auch im Grunde genommen,
So wie wir's, ich sage mal vor zwei Monaten oder vor zweieinhalb Monaten.
Glaube ich, in unser äh Bismarck-Sendung äh da äh auch als Szenario aufgemacht haben und in dem Pfad zwischen,
ja greift ein und ähm,
oder wird wird zum Eingreifen gezwungen, also bisher haben's die Russen ja nicht mal geschafft irgendwie die NATO äh äh wirklich weiter tiefer in den in den in den Konflikten.
Äh hinein äh zu ziehen oder sie zu zwingen, was weiß ich, humanitäre Korridore zu eröffnen oder oder irgendwie äh so was, sondern äh ja.
Bisher ähm hat die Ukraine es,
mehr oder weniger alleine geschafft, damit westlicher Unterstützung, aber ähm so eigentlich doch schon mehr oder weniger aus eigener Kraft und mit überwiegend
eigenen Reserven und eigenen Waffen, die sie vorher hatten, die Russen in Schach zu halten. Und,
hm äh es bleibt jetzt abzuwarten inwieweit.
Jetzt die Waffen, die jetzt gerade beginnen anzurollen. Ähm inwieweit ähm.
Die jetzt dann schon ausreichen, um Reserven aufzubauen und eine Gegenoffensive zu gehen. Ich.
Bin mir da eher sicher, selbst die die meisten Optimisten erwarten nicht, dass vor,
im Ablauf von ein oder zwei Monaten die Ukraine zu einer Gegenoffenoffensive in der Lage sein wird.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das sogar noch noch länger äh äh dauern äh wird, aber.
Was eben auch weiter gilt, tendenziell tickt die Uhr eher äh für die Ukraine und gegen die Russen.
Äh weil äh man sagt ursprünglich vier bis acht Tage waren geplant und ähm
Jeder äh Tag, den die Russen gezwungen sind, weiterzukämpfen, so oder so ist einen Tag länger. Ist ein weiterer Tag länger als geplant. Ja.
Also die Russen fallen täglich weiter hinter ihren Zeitplan zurück. So und hinter ihre ursprünglichen Erwartungen und,
haben ja auch selbst ihre dann mehrfach reduzierten Ziele bisher nicht nicht wirklich erreicht. Und ähm insofern.
Ähm ja Lohn scheint sich das Gegenhalten zu lohnen äh aber ähm ja mit einer Gegenoffensive ist so schnell nicht zu rechnen was man halt nie weiß, ist hm ob.
In einigen Gegenden vielleicht dann doch die Russen einfach dann doch zusammenbrechen, aber das kann genauso gut bei den Ukrainern.
Sein. Also im Zweiten Weltkrieg war's dann
öfter so, dass dann halt irgendwann einzelne Truppen verbinde, einfach aufgerieben wurden und aufhörten schlichtweg zu existieren und dann halt einfach auch
riesige Bereiche frei äh waren und teilweise dann auch Armeen in der Lage waren.
Unter den Bedingungen dann äh fünfzig, 60, 80 Kilometer am Tag äh äh Vormärsche hinzulegen und die Front soweit zu bewegen.
Ja aber von so einer Situation sind wir bisher noch weit entfernt, aber,
wenn's kippt, kann es dann halt manchmal auch ganz schnell kippen, aber es ist nicht zu erwarten, dass es in absehbarer Zeit kippen wird.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt mal einen Schlusspunkt.
Okay, ja. Ich hätte zwar noch eine Kuriosität, die ich eigentlich
Hörer nicht nicht vorenthalten äh wollte, weil die einfach auch so ein bisschen nerdig und äh äh wirklich
kurios ist und einfach auch so ein bisschen mein mein Hirn einfach gesprengt hat und zwar ähm
gibt es ja vielfach diese abgehörten Telefonate russischer Soldaten, die dann von der ukrainischen Geheimdienst meistens ins Netz gestellt und dann von Leuten übersetzt werden und.
Das hier ist ein äh äh wirklich ein Telefonat ähm wo was abgehört und ins Netz gestellt wurde, wo,
ein russischer,
Soldat äh mit seiner Verlobten darüber redet, dass ihr letztes Telefonat abgehört und ins Internet gestellt wurde.
Und,
ihr die Schuld gibt, dass er zu viel erzählt hat, äh weil sie gefragt hat und sie dann jetzt außerdem auch noch gedoxt wurden so und
das Telefonat zusätzlich mit Bildern von Biden und Adressen und allen dann im Internet stand und er hat halt erzählt, wie er da äh ja irgendwelche Ukrainer abgeschlachtet äh hat äh und und so und
äh ja jedenfalls fand ich's erstmal Meta, ja das also sozusagen zuzuhören
Also es ist auch auch dann wie so ein wie so ein Unfall in in in Zeitlupe, dass das Ganze nicht nur, dass er sich komplett zum
Obst macht, sondern dass halt, ja, sie darüber reden, äh und sagen, wie ihr früheres Telefonat abgehört wurde und dass sie doch halt jetzt irgendwie nicht am Telefon vorsichtig sein sollten und das ja und.
Also wirklich wirklich unglaublich, aber äh was mich dann eben auch so geflasht hat, war dass äh äh was für ein Typ.
Ist, ja? Also äh dass er seiner Verlobten die Schuld daran gibt, dass er das Maul nicht halten kann.
Ja das äh und das in einem äh wirklich Telefonat, was es wiederum abgehört hat so. Also das das war.
Ähm wirklich äh was sich da an auch einfach, weiß ich nicht, an an an Dummheit
äh ähm dann plötzlich wiederfindet, die dann im Internet äh ja exponiert äh
wird ähm und gut wir haben ich glaube so viel wie über diesen Krieg äh.
Wurde medial äh noch nie in der Geschichte von Kriegen wahrscheinlich berichtet so direkt von der Front und direkt von.
Die da kämpfen und was dort dann wirklich einfach passiert ist, meiste. Da redet man ja dann ja oft nicht drüber oder,
Ja, aber hier äh kriegen wir's halt dann.
Alles im Internet.
Ich würde sagen, wir machen an der Stelle mal einen Punkt für diese Ausgabe. Vielleicht lassen wir uns mal nicht wieder einen Monat Zeit fürs nächste Update. Äh es gibt auch so ein paar Bereiche, die wir jetzt komplett ausgeklammert haben, die ganze
Frage der Weizenexporte der Ukrainer äh Situation im Schwarzen Meer und so diese internationalen Konstellationen, die sich da gerade ergeben und so dieser
versucht der Russen äh Europa sozusagen auch dahingehend zu schwächen, dass eben auch noch diese ganze Food-Crisis dazukommt mit
potentiellen Auswirkungen bis hin zu neuen Flüchtlingswellen oder was weiß ich äh was die sich da auch alles noch äh ausmalen, was im Prinzip alles noch.
Möglich ist. Ist ja auch alles nur teilweise äh vorhersehbar. Schön ist es auf jeden Fall alles nicht. Wie gesagt,
Wir lassen nicht noch mal einen Monat verstreichen, denke ich. Keine Versprechung, ähm aber äh wir hören uns bald wieder und freuen uns auf eure Kommentare und.
Macht.